Dump,
dump,
dump.
And where live unfortunately moral
Rinaldo is,
is deathly ill and he cannot make it
here,
but the great boss routing boom,
Pasito Guapo is here,
former UFC heavyweight champion.
And your friend Kevin Random and
unfortunately the guy who won the title
from a passed away recently.
That was sad,
Huh?
Yeah.
The conspiracy theory was already on.
I saw on line because he didn't.
Morrow didn't do ww II yesterday
evening.
So they said,
oh,
he was at the funeral of gather edelman.
I said,
no,
that's not true.
He was really sick at home.
But yeah,
that was the,
that was the craziest news we found out
after we just did our podcast and then
we went online and um,
what?
He got sick,
he got sick with pneumonia and then it's
going to revive him.
Well,
he had staph infection worse than
anybody I've ever seen in my life.
Did you ever see some of
pictures?
You know what I said to people,
if you,
if you use smokeless tobacco in that
little box,
you could literally put in that hole
that he had in his chest.
Remember that?
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was insane.
Well,
we'll show the picture.
Jamie,
see if he can find the picture of Kevin
Randleman staph infection.
I never knew that I could get this bad,
but he had holes in his body where you
could look in and you see all the tissue
and attendance.
I mean,
just incredible.
You see it third,
Jamie,
I'm talking like a fist sized hole.
It was crazy.
He,
this guy survived everything as well.
Look at that.
Oh,
it's just incredible.
I just don't.
And he fought after this too by the way.
Up and he fought afterwards.
But when your body is that compromised
from something like that,
I'm assuming that was mercer where the
medication resistant staph infection,
that stuff is real dangerous and people
die from it all the time.
Look at his leg to look how swollen his
ankle and his foot is.
Oh my God.
Very scary.
Oh God.
And Kevin Randleman in his prime mean
what a stud.
What a specimen.
That guy was to see him that
compromised.
I mean,
I don't know if he just ignored it and
it just kept getting worse and worse.
I don't know.
What happened,
I don't know either,
you know,
but I,
I have the feeling that it's like with
all the flights that were pretty much
the same,
you'll probably,
it's the same as well,
you know,
you have something,
you feel bad,
you know,
your launch.
I'll.
Everything is hurting.
Whatever man,
you know,
I'll take care of that tomorrow once it
gets worse,
not realizing because we're pushing all
the limits all the time that it at the
moment you're feeling it's probably
really bad already.
You should check it out,
but you know,
just push it away.
Let's get rid of my.
Let's do my work first and then we'll
take care of that later.
It was too late.
That's the feeling I have.
That is a problem with mental toughness
and some fighters they just keep pushing
through injuries and I've always
suspected that that might be the case
with Cain.
Why cain keeps getting injured over and
over again and now he's starting to get
some serious injuries where he's had
back now,
both shoulder
surgery,
knee surgery.
I mean this is a guy in his prime.
I mean,
I think Kane is only 33 or something
like that.
Right?
He should be regenerating like,
like this now as a heavyweight.
That's your prime.
The early thirties for heavyweight.
So generally when they really come into
their own and to see him constantly
injured,
I've always suspected it's just his
mental toughness is almost like a burden
because he pushes through everything.
You know,
Chris Weidman,
I think the same thing with his knees.
He's had some serious knee problems.
It's because they,
you know,
they have the problem.
They just go,
fuck it.
Let's just keep going.
And they can block out pain in a way
that,
you know,
most people,
they get a series,
knee injury,
that,
boy,
I got to go to.
The doctor got to get this checked out.
Not when you're in the middle of camp
and you're defending your title,
you fucking keep pushing through it.
Yeah.
I'm telling you,
all my students know because I used to
be executive like all the other guys.
I say if you have an injury and the
doctor tells you,
take two months off,
take four months off.
That's my advice.
Now you take double the amount of.
Everybody does the opposite.
Two months,
one month or three weeks.
Yeah,
don't do that because later in life,
like with what happened with me,
it will backfire for you and it's such a
good piece of advice right there because
so many guys,
especially acl surgeries,
how many times have we seen guys get
theirs?
Their knee reconstructed and then they
try to get back on the mat too quick and
pop bumps again.
The new knee blows out again and you're
looking at another six to nine months.
It's so,
so common.
Accrues Elisha Benji redneck.
He had like also like from a,
from an illegal corp.
So he had something in his knee and
illegal courtyard.
They had the fbi.
Yeah,
an illegally obtained.
It waS.
He got a letter from the fbi.
he almost lost his leg and then he had
this.
He,
we went to dinner with him one time.
he had a machine on him that filled
that.
His blood,
everywhere he went,
he got this crazy infection and then
years later he gets a letter from the
fbi and it was the guy who was
illegally,
uh,
it has handled in the end,
donors in the and whatever they need for
knees and for,
uh,
for everything like oregon's.
And they found that guy.
Yeah.
And it was from a cadaver that was
infected.
And that's why we had all that problem.
Yeah,
it was shit.
It was really crazy.
Did he get a discount or something like
maybe later he was just right into it.
Rain check for the other knee happens.
Benji radek is a guy,
a lot of people forgot about it.
Isn't fucking talented guy.
You don't.
I always talented at the time when was
call me crazy when anderson silva was,
had to speak of this career.
I said if I have six monThs with benji
and he would listen to me because
sometimes she gets that ego that,
oh,
I can strike with him.
No,
no,
you don't need to take him down and then
strike him,
you know,
because she would knock people out with
one punch.
This guy hits so hard,
he would hurt my hands on the Focus
mitts.
I'm as the craziest follow he has and
I'm telling you what,
his wrestling was so good.
He would just take him down and just
Beat hIm up.
I guarantee You that,
that that's how powerful he was.
Wow.
You know,
there's a lot
of guys that don't realize their
potential and benji radical was one of
those guys that people would always talk
about and the gym,
you know,
they say like,
boy,
if he could figure out how to put it all
together.
We did a few times at the ifl when he
was training for the anaconda.
She was there.
Yeah.
And then he started listening and people
go like,
man,
he,
you transforming them into a kickboxer.
He's just listening at this moment.
But when you face another guy,
like for instance,
he fought a Scott Smith,
you know,
and I told him,
I said,
don't brawl with the guy.
Yeah,
but are people going to think,
I don't want to blame it on me,
tell them that I set so otherwise I'm
not going to train you anymore.
And of course the fight starts,
smith comes out and he starts brawling
with a guide.
That's what the guy does.
Don't do thIs.
Like with vandelay silva,
don't brawl with the guy.
You know,
you just got to pick them apart from the
outside and she would take him down.
He got in trouble at the end of the
first round.
Then he took him down,
hit him once.
That was the end of the round,
but almost half scotsmen aren't exactly
the same thing where I've lost my voice.
I just stopped yelling.
I said,
why don't you take them down?
It's really that easy for you.
Do it.
But he didn't.
He goes,
a funny thing when guys want to beat
guys at their own game or they want to
show that they're not aFraid to stand
with people.
It's hard to.
You know that that fucking thing that
makes you great in the first place,
that makes you a fighter in the first
place.
A lot of times can BIte you in the ass.
Just don't.
Don't do wHat the other person is best
at.
If there's one thing he's weaker than
yours,
go to that,
whatever it is,
but it was ground literally striking.
Well,
that was one thing that gsp was always
so good at.
He was always so good at imposing his
strength,
like whatever the guy was.
If a guy was good at wrestling,
he would try to keep the fight standing.
If a guy was good at standing,
he would take them down.
You know what I mean?
gsp was so good at that and being
unpredictable too as to what his
approach was going to be.
He thought he was going to strike and
then he's going to take you down.
You think he's going to take you down
and he's going to kick you.
He was like the la jolla,
the la jolla.
Every time when he fought,
he had a new techniques.
He used new combinations and the same
thing happened with gsp.
Every time you saw him,
josh koscheck,
I remember the fight.
It was a jap and was just spinning back,
kick to the body and he nailed it over
and over again.
You knew that for the six weeks,
eight weeks,
whatever he was trading,
they worked on that.
You know,
for the rest of you ad lib a little bit.
What you normally do,
like to know.
Just pepper.
Yeah.
the josh koscheck fight.
man.
That was a.
That was an ugly one.
THat one is.
I swole up like that.
Josh was in a seriously bad shape after
that.
He couldn't fly after that fight.
Yeah,
that was.
That was one where they hear that they
had a drive from.
I think they had that fight in toronto.
Is it toronto and montreal?
I think it was toronto,
right?
No,
no,
that was,
I believe it was montreal because I
think toronto was jake shields.
That was the big one at the roger
center,
right?
I have no clue.
I think so.
Either way.
He was in Canada and he had a drive down
to boston and I believe he had to stay
there for a couple of weeks before he
could even fly back home to san jose.
Wow.
So you think that will blow up in the
air as well?
Again,
it was so bad.
It was an orbital fracture.
There is,
there's a picture of it right there and
that's after the fight,
but it was so bad that they had to
operate on it and those blowout
fractures of the eyes apparently are
extremely painful and very dangerous too
because it's the bone behind the eye
that gets broken so they have to go in
behind the eye and repair that bone and
sometimes when they do that,
your eye ball is never the same again.
It looks different like do you remember
bob sapp after cro?
Cop Hit him in pride,
I believe you called that faculty member
cro.
Cop cracked him with the left hand.
Was it or was it [inaudible]?
No,
it's a.
They'll go,
oh,
wait a minute.
It game watching.
I think it was know it was because I was
actually training.
Bob said,
well,
whenever you call it training,
I trained them one and a half times the
rest.
He was doing interviews.
Oh really?
I go,
dude,
this guy right now in Croatia,
he's kicking it back.
He wants to kill you because you're on
the top the now you just beat the host.
Yeah.
Is crazy that he beat him.
So,
uh,
yeah.
Then he came to train with me because I
told him before the fight,
but he said,
if you would fight me,
why would you go for.
I go,
I go full body shots because your
stamina and I kick your knees instead of
your legs.
I kick your knees because you have to
carry that weight all the time.
Who dropped him two or three times with
the liver shot?
So after that he came.
He said,
I really want to train with you.
I said,
okay,
well then I'm going to be in Japan
anyway,
so let's,
let's work out.
But yeah,
he was still busy doing media.
I said,
don't do that.
He was such a superstar in Japan.
He had to capitalize the amount of money
he was able to make.
I think people in America realized how
big for those few years.
Bob sapp got it.
Pan.
You have no clue.
We went out to dinner with him and that
they have to close the restaurant and
have to let them out at the back because
you see one person in the front,
two,
four,
and there was a whole group,
couldn't get out anymore.
You couldn't go through the lobby of the
hotel and it's not like he can blend in
a 375 pound man.
Huge.
He was.
This was in the tokyo post.
They had a picture of him on the cover
coming out of a like a massage place and
he saw this little girl thanked him and
here's the amount and the man stands
there and all these little girls that
had that little black thing in front of
their eyes,
you know that they do so you don't know
who that person is still there and he
was upset.
He said,
why didn't they put one in front of my
eyes?
I go,
yeah,
blocked
your whole ad.
People are going to go a while.
When he was fighting in pride,
I mean he was like a character from a
movie.
he was like the boss in a video game.
You remember?
Oh yeah,
god,
it was hilarious.
He did all these dances,
the bulb,
seb dance,
and they go to every shape and every
show and you had to just love him.
He's a.
He's a Freak and you know what,
the first time when he fought against
nogueira I go,
dude,
we got to hear from this.
This guy,
he,
he was doing really well against a
seasoned guy like nogueira eventually.
Okay.
Last.
But he just started.
I think if you would have kept focusing
on the same training that he did at the
time,
it would've been a much,
much tougher guy because he had a lot of
talented physically at least.
Well,
he was just so fucking big to.
Maurice was training him at that time.
yeah.
Maury smith was working with a med and
married
there.
We're working with his kickboxing and
they're really trying to put some
technique to all that muscle,
but you know,
you're talking about a guy who
legitimately was 375 pounds with abs.
I mean,
he was like a science project in the
history of performance enhancing drugs.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean,
is there a bit of project is he's like,
this is as far as you can push it before
you fucking explode,
before your skin just explodes.
Like a water balloon.
Oh man.
Yeah,
we see it the past.
You see that with these guys who use a
latino,
they always are around to fight as they
start to become purple,
you know,
and then suddenly here they died of a
heart attack and so I wonder what
happened there?
Well,
he made it through.
He survived and then he started just
quick tapping.
He started doing all these fights where
he would get hit,
why he would go in hard and if it didn't
work out he would just tap and he fought
a bunch of guys like that where he would
start off the fight really well and then
wind up tapping out just and they would
fight again like three weeks.
Do the same thing.
It just kept doing it.
Living off of the name that he had
created while he was in pride.
That's a very sad thing for me that
that's almost the same as going on the
street then beg for money.
It really is to me,
you know,
I think that is a man.
He's such a good guy if you meet him.
Oh so very,
very nice guy.
But yeah,
that I,
I,
I don't like that.
It's the same occur,
you know what I saw that special thing
that they did on him,
but he sells cars now.
You know,
it's,
it's hard to look at that because
especially he knew where he was in the
past and that old is gone now you know,
it's,
you can be really high,
but you can fall really low.
Yeah.
And yeah,
he had fired a saying that they said
it's so great to fight this as but when
you're high,
you know when you're.
When.
But when the lows are,
their is really low as well.
The difference is too much.
Well actually,
uh,
look what just came out with ellen and
rhonda.
I mean she broke down just thinking
about it now and it's a moment that are
there.
So everybody would have that for a few
seconds,
but yeah,
it get you down because like that,
I know that after the fight that night
she was just devastated.
But of course,
I mean that was a brutal,
brutal knockout and it was a fight where
nothing worked.
I mean just nOthing worked.
She went after holly and she tried to
bully her and holly just great footwork
countered her and that kickboxing and
her movement.
Holly's movement is the best in all of
women's mma or footwork and movement.
She's so good At getting out of the way
at countering when you're coming in and
the style,
the bulldog style of rhonda has.
Especially the way she fought that fight
that night,
just played right into holly zahn.
that's it.
She knew exactly what she was going to
be able to time because she just wants
before forward
and that head kick,
whew.
you know,
that was one of the things that I said
after that fight,
I'm like,
this is.
She should take a long time off after
that fight because that's the kind of
head kick that's the kind of kao that it
takes a long time to recover from.
You might look fine,
you know,
you might be able to talk,
but mentally and also the brain itself,
that kind of an impact like a high kick
like that can really take a long time
for everything.
He'll for Anything to normalize.
Well,
kenny rice that she says no because I
took my words back because if we're
talking about a floyd mayweather versus
rhonda said,
well,
if it goes to the ground,
you know?
Yeah,
I,
I truly believe,
but kenny said footwork on,
make sure it's not going to go to the
grant.
I go,
no,
no.
Five rounds,
five minutes,
25 minutes.
I'll a long time.
He knows there will be a clinch one
time,
but that's exactly what happened.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's a difference.
First of all,
in fighting in an octagon,
which is a huge surface.
Like if you look at a boxing ring,
most people you can look them up much,
much smaller space.
And also I just don't think rhonda would
try to box a floyd mayweather.
I think she thought that she could stand
with holly holm.
Yep.
And I think a lot of is based on holly's
previous performances in the ufc,
especially the raquel pennington fight.
Yokel pennington who was very tough,
very durable.
And I've read rico,
I always give her.
I gave her the nickname of the ear
exploder because she's had so many
moments in the fight where you like,
screamed so loud that you blow people's
eardrums out.
Like,
um,
when she fought Ashley,
evan smith and bulldog choked her.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Blood everywhere.
And she talked to her like one second
ago.
We were screaming at the end of that
fight.
Like she's out.
She's out.
And then she but pennington so tough and
fought conservatively against holly holm
and almost one like that was a split
decision.
So you look at that fight and he go,
well boy man,
maybe rhonda could stand with her and
just go after the way.
She went after bench go,
hey,
uh,
the race she went after a Alexis Davis,
but man holly was just on point.
It was game planning also,
you know,
after that fight with raquel,
that was perfect for her because that
means,
okay,
stay away from the big bumps,
you know,
and they know that rhonda,
she's an athlete,
she can hit,
she hit you.
When I saw that,
um,
what is the open workout in Brazil?
And I'm one of these guys,
I have always thinks to say,
oh,
does not good.
You should do that.
You can prove this.
You know,
I'm always,
I'm very critical and I always think to
myself,
am I too much?
Is that what am I doing?
But at the moment I saw her training
there and this is,
this is not fighting and I know this
doesn't translate to fighting by hitting
the focus mitts and hitting the bag or
all that stuff.
It looked nearly perfect to me.
The rotation of her upper body,
the movement afterwards to move very
taste.
and like also,
I really thought,
man,
yeah,
okay.
I have nothing to say now.
This looks really good.
I felt the same way.
Yeah.
I felt like our hand techniques were on
point and then when she polished off
beds cohere and the first round it's
sort of spoke to that like,
okay,
well look,
obviously she.
She hits hard.
Her technique is improving and she's an
elite athlete.
Yup.
You're talking about an olympian.
You're talking about a person that has
that mindset to push forward and figures
out a way to get better at everything
she does,
but so does holly.
Yep.
So does holly and holly has got way
better kickboxing skills and way better.
She's got way more diversity in her
striking game where it was.
Ron is just punching knees to the body
when she gets close to the clench.
Nice the body,
but on the outside it's just punching.
Where's holly?
Holly can head kick you and knock you
the fuck out.
And she sets those kicks up with kicks
to the body.
She'll throw kicks to leg.
That jackson camp.
They all liked that oblique kicked in
the thigh.
This is a dangerous kick.
Yeah,
it's going to be a lord.
And when somebody is going to snap their
knee,
it's going to be over.
Do you think so because knee bars are
now allowed heel hooks on outlawed.
I know,
but that's a different thing.
You know,
you do this is once your leg is a little
stretched and you get hit there.
Oh yeah,
that's it.
A knee bar or you have to be in a
polyamorous,
you know.
But anybody else,
we just put the knee bar on and give you
time to tap.
Won't have that.
We'd no bleed cake.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
I mean,
but it's so effective right now when
it's legal.
I understand why they're using it.
[inaudible] jon jones is so good at it
and it doesn't.
You know,
winkle john is one of the best striking
coaches in the world.
He really is so good and so
underappreciated because he's such a
humble guy.
He doesn't.
He's not talking a lot.
It's not bragging.
He's a very down to earth,
normal,
humble guy.
But the results that that guy has been
able to.
I mean,
holly is probably one of his best
students,
but of course
jon,
I'm not a freak.
He can change the world.
He could be if he,
if he's now on the straight and narrow
and he's just fighting.
I see this guy,
nobody's going to beat this guy.
It's going to be,
is going to be hard,
that's for sure.
But you know,
the worry about john is that john's
going to fuck himself up because like
recently he just got caught driving with
no license and no insurance and no
registration and you know,
he lost his license.
He get,
he's got millions of dollars.
Get a fucking driver,
man.
Yeah.
But look at tiger woods.
What happened to him?
Because when all the crap happened with
him,
he mentally,
he didn't come back from that.
And I understand this is golf,
you know,
but same as fighting.
It's some,
it's a mind game.
It's really a mind game.
So kenny overstepped that.
I think he can because jones is young
and he knows how good he is.
But if,
if I were him,
I say fight for five more years is stop
you going down in history like a
thousand years from now,
they will still talk about you if you do
it correctly or you know,
he sidetracks and something bad's gonna
happen to them.
Let's not help.
Yeah,
I hope he pulls it together.
He's a great guy.
I really liked john as a person.
I mean he has his flaws like most people
and he's young and the amount of
pressure that he's on to be the youngest
ever ufc champion to have this
spectacular career.
So early in life.
The only loss he had was a
disqualification.
That was a bullshit disqualification.
This,
this stupid rule of 12 to six elbows.
They got to get rid of that.
If we don't know what I'm talking about,
folks in the ufc,
there's a rule and it's a crazy rule
that you can't strike someone with an
elbow from 12,
12:00 PM to six on a clock dial,
like going straight down.
AnD the only reason why you can't do it
is because when they were setting up the
athletic commissions,
the athletic commissions had seen those
karate demonstrations on tv where a guy
would break a brick with his elbow and I
said,
well,
you can't do that.
That's got to be illegal because someone
could die and this is what big John
Mccarthy told me that he had to talk to
these people.
And he's like,
oh,
okay.
All right.
Then that was illegal.
So that's the only reason why that's
still illegal.
But the great thing is if you're on your
back,
you're allowed to do it because that is
the
dumbest thing ever.
It's so stupid.
It's one of the dumbest rules that's
still in place.
Yeah.
Oh,
well that's.
We had a guy in holland,
he police,
he pulled it and wheat orlando with
these two guys.
When they fought each other,
they will sell out all the time.
I saw three fights of them live because
these guys were crazy at full tie rules
and alondo wheat and he put both of
them.
They would end the clench,
like jump all the way up.
And then come down with our.
Most of the collarbones do that.
They will go full blast.
Orlando,
we who fought in the ufc,
I think ufc two.
Was it two?
We fought against the rem co.
Pardot.
Pardot?
Yeah.
He got him in a scarf and elbows with
illegal elbows.
Now it is illegal and so true.
Right?
Well it might've been legal because it
was kind of coming from 12 on the side.
Maybe it was like 12 to seven or
something like 11,
five or one to seven.
It's up to you what you want to go.
It's so dumb.
I,
you know,
I have a problem with a few rules of the
ufc,
but that's the number one.
That's the number one.
Have also a problem with the putting the
hand on the ground and stop news.
The head.
I always go if you have somebody lifted
him up.
Yeah.
I feel like to down deponent,
maybe that's a problem when they're up
against the cage because you can't get
your head out of the way.
Like in pride.
One of the crazy things about pride,
which I think to this day and one of the
reasons why I was so excited to have
moral here too,
you guys called the glory days.
I mean some of the wildest fights in the
history of the sport.
Yep.
Where you have stomps soccer,
kicks everything but no elbows,
no elbows to the ground.
Yeah.
No,
I,
I remember fights that
they literally have ventilators silver
in the corner over or ninja or shogun,
you know,
and it would hold the ropes.
Just stomp somebody skullen pretty much.
it's scary.
I think that that shouldn't,
that shouldn't be legal.
It's like what happened in the past with
the hydro huerta one fc now one
championship.
When you look at their fight,
you go,
that was the referee really messed up on
that one.
He liteRally dropped on all fours
because he was exhausted and then he get
penalty kicked in the face that,
that could've been really bad.
Well,
I think it was really bad.
I mean I don't know how much he
recovered from that.
That was a devastating knockout and it
was also roger fighting at one 70.
Which is not really his weight class.
It really should be a 1:55 and he fought
a big.
Who's the brazilian guy that he fought?
Don't remember his name,
but that guy's a big guy and he.
He had roger hurt and then that soccer,
they have like a rule at one fc.
I don't know if they still have it where
they,
they'll say like open,
like what?
You're allowed to do,
stomp or a kick to the downed opponent.
Well,
this was a closed set.
There was the guy's name,
zorro Babo a,
a man above it.
It was a devastating,
devastating soccer here.
He said,
I did not want to throw the kick.
Wow.
Well then don't.
Why would you do it?
Do it.
Which will be very dangerous at that
moment as well because you're breathing,
you're going to crack some rich,
so it can be very dangerous as well,
but you can recover from the crack ribs
a lot better than you can step away.
There's no need for that.
I never had that.
You know,
it means being aware indicates and know
what you're doing.
You know,
if I see a guys our guys out,
it's not going to hit them an extra.
Yeah,
it's,
there's a lot of debate about the old
rules of pride versus the rules of the
ufc and that was one of the things that
happen when cro cop started fighting in
the ufc and then fought in a cage for
the first time against gonzaga.
Well,
you know,
he fought eddie sanchez first won that
fight,
but that was not on his level.
And then he fought gonzaga gonzaga,
took him down,
held them up against the cage,
elbow the shit out of them,
and then stood them up and high kicked
him.
But he was saying like the elbows
confused him.
Like he wasn't used to that and he also
wasn't used to the cage being trapped.
Whereas the pride ring,
you could move around like the ropes
were there.
You can get under the ropes.
He could,
you know,
you'd never know
you can,
but you can look somebody up also in a
corner,
which you cannot do in a cage.
When I stepped for the first time into a
cage,
I was like,
oh dude,
this is,
this is awesome.
They can never look me up.
This is the biggest thing I've ever
seen.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
yeah.
I think gonzaga,
that fight an elvis come back to this.
I thought that was so smart what he was
doing.
He was constantly throwing the right
hand and it didn't even come close to
his face like this.
And I'm constantly thinking,
why is he doing that?
And then it
re,
you know,
I got,
oh he's shutting his gig down because
woke up.
He might think if I just drove right
stRaight like every 20 seconds in front
of your face,
he's going to think if I throw my left
at the moment he throws that ride
straight,
he's going to knock me out.
So he shut his whole game down and then
he was moving to the left and that was,
that was the blueprint to coco because
after that everybody started doing it.
Yeah.
And it's interesting how cro,
cro,
cop got his revenge in the rematch in a
big way with elbows on the ground.
Seems kind of ironic that one of the
things that cro cop was saying before
that fight is that he didn't
particularly like grappling and he
didn't particularly like elbows on the
ground.
Meanwhile,
that's what won him the fight.
The second fight he won by being on top
and but the elbows that are real
talented striker can throw from the
guard.
The difference in those elbows is just
unbelievably devastated.
And we saw that in the cro.
Cop fight.
Yep.
No,
he did a really good job that I had at
one time.
Also,
somebody's arm barred me and I,
I got out when I fought him the second
time.
I didn't want to knock him out.
I want to bar him first and I remembered
that armbar him the rope escape there.
I had him and then he wrote escapes and
I told him,
I said,
so this is pancreas.
This is bankers.
I said,
no,
you got it back.
And then later on I heal.
Hooked him actually will had crazy
rules.
You and you were the first guy to figure
those rules out and I loved watching you
fight back then because it was openhand
striking with the hands but kicks.
So like you were with the first guy that
ever saw a fight in that.
First of all,
that kicks so fucking hard.
You could see when you would slam these
guys with these kicks,
they'd be like,
oh,
this is a completely different
experience,
but also you weren't slapping.
You would see how the fuck.
Do you pull your hand back so far?
Yeah,
I got very limber.
Hands the bone.
Yeah.
You were pulling your hand way back and
throwing straight punches and hooks and
upper cuts.
like when you fly food narky throwing
upper cut.
Like a punch.
The same motion.
Nobody does this still.
Look,
if I'm in the garden and I,
I just lift my hand like this.
See?
Yeah.
Just slide over his chest and face.
Why is nobody doing this?
Why is nobody just leave it here?
Just hit them a little bit.
Look away.
Because most of them,
when you look away,
they think and the book just flat hand
on the center of the chest and just
shove it over the chest.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
That does make sense.
But wouldn't that work with a punch as
well with.
Yeah,
but you have more space wIth a poem on
this distance.
This is much shorter than this.
This is like an extra 15 percent,
which will make a lot of difference.
That's that distance.
That's a very good point.
That's another five or six inches at
least.
Listen,
that's why I never understood nobody
strong palm strikes.
Now that left hook,
right?
Straight combination,
right in boxing,
right.
It's a dumb combination.
If you really think about it.
If it's a short left hook,
I'm way too close to my straight punch.
It has no power.
I can't stretch my,
but if I do a palm strike and then a
straight punch,
now I got space for my straight punch.
It's much harder.
So why is nobody doing that?
Now?
I do closed lines and I posted a thing
on facebook like a year ago when I hit a
bag with a clothesline.
Dude,
I don't think people can imitate me.
My weight with a kick like that,
they can kick and then I said,
okay,
now I show clothesline.
Is she the back folding or out?
My whole arm is the courageous thing.
You can blog with ting had tried to
block whatever you want.
If I close line,
you have to stand still.
It goes straight through everything.
I guarantee you and knock you out.
Why is that?
Why is it clothes on so power?
It is so powerful because you can really
lock it up.
Don't stretch your arm because if you
miss time and you hit your,
you're going to hyperextend,
but you can drag your whole body weight
in there because you will like it and
your legs are planted on the ground.
Oh yeah.
You're getting all that hip torquing.
It is such a powerful strike and also
with the clench when even when they
stand like this,
if I do this,
it loops around to defense and it's the
mecca to had still the legal part
because it's outside the mohawk.
Well,
he's in the back of the head.
Standing never seems to get,
like in boxing they get penalized for
punching the back of the head.
People say no rabbit punches,
but when you think About a head kick,
a lot of headaches,
especially ones that go over the
shoulder there,
there the back of the head and it's,
and it's legal and that's why they're
effective.
And that's why it was so effective with
me with,
uh,
with uh,
with pancreaS.
I hid behind the ear.
If you look at mike dyson's fights,
you know,
I don't know how he did it,
but he did it.
He was always the shorter guy.
But if you see him hooking somebody,
he hits almost the back of their head.
He's got very short hooks now the body,
it's ready for impact from the front,
from the side,
because you're used to it.
well,
if you could see the punch coming,
the behind,
I always tell people just do with a
poem,
just do this to the back of your head
and see what happens.
So like just me doing this,
it's all ready to go.
You're not ready for that.
So you can already imagine if you go hit
as hard as you can be here.
It's a sweet.
It's a sweet bunch.
I can understand that,
but it's doing it.
Whereas the head that much more
dangerous.
Oh,
do this,
do this.
But I mean,
is it that much more data than just
behind it?
Here?
Just do that.
Oh you,
you
remember?
Um,
when the hens old fart and world combat
against that judo guy.
I'm a,
I forget the dutch guy.
Yeah,
he got his back and spikers spike as
best baker by trade with them.
Also got his back and just bet if they,
if you can elbow the back of the head
rear naked,
choke her out the window,
but it's just going to bang bang to the
back of the head.
And it's almost more effective than a
rear naked choke because kaiser just
gonna they're just gonna try to cover
up.
Yeah.
And eventually,
yeah,
slIp through that.
It's interesting to me that there's some
really effective martial arts techniques
that are outlawed and that's one of
them.
You can't hit that spot.
It's,
it's,
it's kind of strange because In a self
defense situation or an actual martial
arts,
if
you think about what is the most
effective technique to use,
knees the ground are very effective to
head on a down opponent.
Elbows to the back of the head are very
effective.
But are they that much more dangerous
much?
Should they be outlawed?
Oh,
here's the video.
Yeah,
henzel.
Got it.
Oh,
look at this.
Boom,
boom.
I mean no need to choke,
but he choked him anyway,
I think.
Yeah,
I know he's going to step on his head.
Right?
Smashed him.
He smashed that dude.
Well that guy.
Here's the deal.
Henzel,
who's a very nice guy.
By the way.
This fucking guy was calling hensville
all throughout the night and fucking
with them.
Look at.
He's.
Yeah,
he's out cold.
Henzel was in his hotel room and this
guy kept calling them and fucking with
him.
He just didn't want him to have any
sleep,
so it just kept ringing his phone and I
was like,
oh,
okay.
Wait,
motherfucker.
Yeah.
It's so funny when you see a guy like
heads and he's always smiling,
you know,
don't do it.
What's wrong with people?
He's really nice.
He smiles all the time,
but he does the same thing when he gets
you in the balls,
you know,
watch out.
Did you ever see that twitter,
a sequence that hensville put online
will beat the shit out of these muggers
in New York city.
These guys in New York city tried to mug
henzel gracie not knowing who he was,
so hands on,
not only beat the fuck out of him,
he followed them and kept beating the
fuck out of them and make all these
pushes.
Thank you mayor bloomberg for making so
safe,
newer.
Don't have to worry about guns.
This to me is a pleasure.
You already starts with.
There are still guys following us.
They probably wanted to rob me or
something and then he makes.
It was like,
oh yeah,
this is really happening.
I'm so excited.
What a huge fuck up on their part.
Well,
he had one.
We were,
kenny arise now were somewhere.
This is not that long ago.
And he was also,
he was walking on the street and two
guys,
same thing.
He came to tell the story and uh,
and he,
he dropped the Biggest guy,
right?
He said,
I just picked the biggest next month and
why he kept walking.
The police came,
they stopped us trouble and he looks at
the guys and the guys go,
no,
it doesn't.
No,
it's fucking.
He says,
you just picked the wrong guy.
He told them they fuck you.
Good.
Yeah.
Well,
he looks so friendly and nice.
You know,
I mean,
when,
when he's got his game face on,
he looks like a killer,
but most of the time,
hence off smiling.
He's like one of those smileys happiest
guys you're ever going to run into.
And they look at them.
They're big smile.
Oh,
that's.
Is that an ifl ifl ring?
But it's,
this is the paperweight,
this is another really big one,
is a paperweight that they gave to us
and the hens or couldn't be a nicer guy,
couldn't be a nicer guy.
And it's so nice to see how well he's
done with his school too.
He has one of the biggest jujitsu
schools in the world.
Yep.
In,
in manhattan where it's so hard to be
successful because it's so expensive.
Real estate.
I think the ifl had a big part in that
because they did a thing on 20 slash 20
for him and,
or 15 minutes,
one of the two.
And,
and after that it just exploded because
once you get into the world of enzo,
you know about what kind of person he
is,
you know,
everyone likes him,
even even the guys like him.
so to people at home,
they saw that guy and then they saw the
technique and uh,
you know,
talent.
Yeah,
put hand in hand together and boom,
anthony bourdain trains.
They're also,
his wife,
trains.
Everybody turns out,
well,
he's done an amazing job of putting
together a fantastic gym in New York
city with gary tonin,
eddIe common,
so he's got these guys that are in john
danaher is a big part of that as well.
He's got these guys that are trained
there that are so successful in these
jujitsu competition,
so it's not just the legacy of being one
of the gracies and being one of the most
famous jujitsu practitioners ever,
but it's also on top of that,
it's the product,
like the results that they've gotten in
competition.
Yeah,
he's very smart.
You know,
he's got a really good staff as well
teaching there,
which is a very important thing because
most of the time guys who are really
good,
they want to control it too much,
you know,
and then it goes down.
Like he did a great job just gettiNg the
right guys for the job.
What's also,
you see extreme loyalty from the people
that train there because they love hanzo
so much.
Like there's like a real bond with
henzel gracie.
Of course you don't.
Matt serra who came from that lineage
and then you know,
a lot of his guys as well just can't say
enough good things about him.
It's funny.
It's hilarious.
then the one that's the first time
looking for a fight.
You're a model
and then it gets old comfortable sitting
in a certain way.
It's so funny if you haven't seen it,
there's a show called looking for a
fight and it's dana white,
matt,
sarah and nick the tooth.
And what they do is they go to small mma
shows all over the world and uh,
they see fights and find talent and
that's where they find that kid go sage
northcutt as well.
And then the guy who was,
who they were setting up to fight bunk.
Yeah.
Cm punk,
which is a.
I don't know what's going to happen with
that guy.
I don't understand this whole thing.
She got a lot of injuries.
Well,
I also think it's ridiculous for him to
fight in the ufc.
I think he should fight in a small
organization.
Take a fight in a small organization,
build yourself up.
I have always said that that's what
should have happened with brock lesnar.
I mean,
if you look at brock lesnar as an
athlete,
I always said if you took brock lesnar
and got him to a guy like matt hume,
or for us a hobby and said,
okay,
make this guy a chance.
You're dealing with a freak athlete.
Unreal.
Just train them correctly.
Building them up,
building them up slow,
get them through the right.
But he wanted to fight right away in the
ufc one fighting k one right to the ufc
fought and that k one la show.
Yup.
Um,
and then right to the ufc.
Yeah,
it's a shame,
you know,
and,
but,
but it's his name and then,
you know,
david,
they,
of course,
they understand that once he fights were
a baby has got to be a lot of people.
He's going to have a gun into bayview,
but that,
that is short.
It's always short.
Like the money later in your career,
your greg,
all these things.
I'm happy I never did
that.
Yeah,
I feel like make big mistakes.
Well,
I feel like he,
um,
he definitely had massive potential.
I mean,
he beat,
I mean he beat randy couture.
Yeah,
I mean that's just unbelievable.
I mean he beat the shit out of frank
mir.
I mean he beat shamed carlin and a
fight.
We're really out to show his resilience,
got the fuck beat out of him in the
first round.
Came back,
submit them in the second round.
So we had some legit wins against legit
guys,
but just wasn't ready for guys like cain
or especially allister.
That was it.
It was a bad foot.
Well,
if he could have taken it to the ground,
it would have been different against
goto or.
That was the first time that I thought,
oh,
hopefully now more people start doing
it.
That was that crazy punch.
And wiTh him it was because she was not
super technically yet striking,
but he hit an overhead and it hit with
this part of the hand with the fist,
the back of the head down.
Then with junior dos santos knocked out
cain velasquez like that.
I go,
okay,
we got it.
People finding out they start getting it
to it and then the laskers did the same
thing to junior coming back,
so I figured,
oh,
they looked at it,
so now we're going to see this more
often.
But that was pretty much it.
You see it here and there one time,
but it's not a real overhead or data
throw real over and not with the site.
Then hits the back of the head again.
What we just talked about.
You almost like a ridge hands try.
It's almost like a richard.
Yep.
Well you remember when chocolate
delicioso throw that you got to
chocolate liddell's sweatshirt on those
new routes of fight ones,
right?
Yeah.
Had a boss one t shirt at home.
Oh you guys got one chocolate deli said
throw it like over the top of his head.
Like he would.
He would throw this crazy one and that's
how he hit allister when they find him
pride,
he threw it like,
like not a.
Not circular at all,
but like,
like a 12 slash six punch,
you know?
It's a complete different punch.
that's what I tell people.
I said,
how do I say,
I've always really liked the technique
from chuck is he's also wide open.
A bitch gives them almost power equal
left or right,
so just like the and just I like to
fight like that as well and he can hit
really,
really hot and he's not afraid about
opening up.
Sometimes though with him,
you know,
if he gets too excited instead of
stepping back,
he goes in for the kill and that got him
in trouble later in his career because
if you would simply step back and come
back.
But that's why every person,
every guy,
every,
everybody likes chocolate l you don't
look at chocolate day,
say,
oh,
he lost a couple of times by knockout.
Nobody will say that.
He did not lose one fan because he's
always there to fight.
That's why I really liked chuck.
Yeah.
He had one of the most exciting
attitudes ever in fighting.
He was always do or die and early in his
career he had an incredible chin.
Chin was just iron.
You ever see the palae fight when he
fought and valley tudo in Brazil?
No.
No,
I heard about it though.
It was crazy,
crazy fighting that that was a fight
where they had a net under the bottom
rope.
They fought in a ring,
but it was modified for valley tuto
where the bottom rope from the bottom,
the to the floor
of the ring was a net going get out.
They're trapped,
bare knuckle and chuck's got hIm trapped
in there and just beating the fuck out
of them,
like smushed up there.
And this was back when,
you know,
chuck was known for his striking,
but he was a very good wrestler.
Yep.
Before that.
Yeah,
that's why I stopped everything though,
you know,
that was one of the things that,
what the fuck was his name?
the guy who,
uh,
was the matchmaker for the ufc already.
John perretti.
John perretti told chuck right before he
fought his first fight in the ufc.
He said,
if you take this guy down,
you'll never fight for us again.
Oh wow.
That's like somebody said it to chuck
right before he fought and they didn't
want them to try to wrestle.
Fuck his way.
So chuck was like,
oh jesus,
all right,
that's the debut of chuck liddell.
You know,
who knew,
hey,
I got great hair
power.
Well you hit,
hit,
hit hackleman.
His trainer is also a legend,
you know,
and uh,
a great guy and a real wild man too.
They were a perfect combination,
you know,
hackleman and chuck.
No,
chuck's early days.
You,
you know,
you watched some of those fights like
the bob lou fight.
I mean,
he was just a fucking destroyer as the
cake,
right?
That was the,
that was the second time they fought,
right?
Wasn't it?
I don't worry about
if we have morrow here,
he'll uh,
he'll,
he'll tell the dates.
EverytHing.
Well with mom
tomorrow gets better.
We'll definitely have a backer.
I would,
I would love to talk to them.
I love morrow.
He's such a great guy.
He really is.
We have some crazy stores in Japan also
because we,
everything was just fun.
We would come home or we will come home.
We will eat breakfast in Japan.
You know,
you wake up early because if the jetlag
were there at 5:30 window,
breakfast place opens.
We sit down and our table,
we start with two,
it will be at the end,
25 guys out there.
Everybody jumps up there because it's
comedy central all morning on all the
fighters.
You know,
everybody's laughing,
everybody's having a good time.
Well,
you guys did a lot of that
comedy sketches to.
There was a lot of fun with pride in
those early years days.
In the early day she had.
This was just a.
That was with the quarters,
the quarters,
they allowed us to do this and it all
happened because I forgot my suit.
I didn't know that.
As a commentator you needed to wear a
suit so they thought I was messing with
them.
I go,
no,
I really didn't bring us.
Nobody told me to bring a certain.
So I was in my shorts,
flip flops and had this hawaiian shirt
on and that was the first one that I'm
hitting back and there's a bunch of
these acacias.
They're fannIng me down a feeding me
grapes and I'm doing.
I'm talking to steven who is in the
event,
you know,
we're going back and forth and they say,
hey man,
we really liked that.
Maybe we should keep doing this.
and then we started coming up with this
crazy opening.
Well,
a lot of what you were doing,
it was,
I don't even know if I was working for
the ufc back then,
but guys from jujitsu we would all get
together.
We'd either go over my friend john's
house where we go over my house and we
get together with a bunch of guys and we
would watch pride and ah,
those were the days.
So were the days because that,
it was the early days of mma and you
know,
we had had in the nineties you'd have
the,
which was kind of struggling at the time
because they were kicked off a cable and
the only way you could get it was on
direct tv.
This is presumed Was before zoo
football.
But that's like right up around the time
where pride started.
Take off with a first hixon fight in a
lot of people don't know.
Hixon started off pride.
Yup.
Hickson was in pride month.
Yeah.
Takota.
That was the first fight.
A second.
Robert put them on a map by beating the
gracious.
Yeah.
That's when it became big.
That's why I always say,
you know,
for reason for that is rising that they
need.
They need a sacral rob.
I like.
I didn't need a japanese guy.
They,
they could do a few shows like this with
a fade or an ankle and vandelay silva
coming back and they can do a few shows,
but eventually people want to root for
their own.
You know,
they needed the japanese guy like South
Africa.
You remember in k one?
He was getting very.
I think he won the first one,
but that was before all the foreigners
gaming ones,
the seek it teach you and all the.
That was an animal bronco knocked out.
Who's,
oh man,
fuck,
I could fuck it.
We saw the yelp a,
the whole in holland.
That's.
That was the fame.
Most famous place.
Every fight was there always.
That was one night.
We had four guys from Thailand who were
there and they were fighting old guys
from magiro gym like rob cayman,
mila.
Well globally.
I mean all,
all the great guys hold a great strikers
flamenco at a world title fights and it
was broadcast live to Thailand.
Wow.
They all got knocked out.
That never happened again.
After that.
They destroyed him.
It was awesome.
What was it?
That was the holland days of,
you know,
the,
the top holland guys when right around
the time where ramon dekkers started
dominating and rob came and started
dominating so much talent came out of
holland in holland is a small country.
If you look at the size of holland,
do you look at the amount of high level
kick boxers that have come out of there?
It's pretty incredible.
You know,
you did the k one for instance.
They at the end,
from the final eight,
they fight all year.
They make a final tournament for the
people who don't understand it.
They fight 10 times a year or 10 shows
year and then in decemBer does the final
aid,
like the ufc started,
eight fighters the best from the whole
year compete against each other.
Whoever wins gets like 40 to $50,000,
whatever the price money is.
But they start realizing that the final
aids were six were dutch,
seven words show now,
if you will,
for instance,
in a guy who was born in Morocco but
lives in holland or even when you were
born in a moroccan parents,
you know,
suddenly you come up with the moroccan
flag because they say we can have the
perfect example.
Roman vegas.
The first guy I saw,
first time I saw him fight,
I wasn't the same cart I was fighting as
well.
So this is,
this is long time ago.
This was just see class,
you know,
in holland you have new c class b class
a class.
And um,
and I just started.
So I probably was new and fought c class
I
believe.
And a friend of mine calls me,
says,
you're going to watch.
I said,
no,
I got to fight.
I got a warm up.
He says,
do you want to watch this?
Get was just get.
And I see him and he's with the little
mullet and he is skinny and he fights
this guy who was much older than he was
like 16,
17 years old,
an older guy with tattoos.
So automatically you go,
I'm going to get killed.
And my buddy goes,
just wait til he starts,
you know.
And the first gig I don't,
I still remember he kicked a guy,
a low kick and the guy horizontal right
horizontal and fell on the ground.
I'm looking at my buddy.
I go as the craziest power I've ever
seen.
It was so explosive and he was so skinny
at the time,
but his technique was perfect.
His technique was perfect and he was so
ferocious.
Yeah,
I mean he didn't care.
Like when towards the end his ankles
were so fucked up that he wanted to
fight southpaw because he started.
He didn't want to throw the right kick,
but he would.
He would kick a few times and we'd go
fuck it and go right back to it.
And with his bad leg,
I mean they were telling him like,
we're,
we're close to amputating your leg.
You've broken your foot so many times.
You broken your shin,
your,
your whole leg is just a series of.
And he would wrap it up tight and just
still wants to fight started.
He didn't give a fuck and just throw it
right into elbows.
He'd kick everything.
Our motto,
suck it.
He would just place it back in the
corner and the core hammers his trainer.
He told me,
I never heard him complain.
Like he would say,
oh,
you know,
I hurt my ankle or I hurt my hand.
He said,
I had never heard him say anything.
when he comes back,
he goes,
what are you doing?
I'm putting my shoulder,
but I can put this under the socket.
It was almost like it wasn't his body.
Yeah.
Like he was using a borrowed body.
Crazy guy,
man.
Super good.
You know,
that's kevin,
kevin randleman freak of nature.
I mean,
he could have done any,
any sport,
you know,
guys like that.
And that's where ramon dekkers too and
happy they found finding though.
Yeah,
well ramon dekkers really set the
standard.
He really set the standard for ferocity
and he sort of embodied that holland
style,
the dutch style of more tie where they
just.
I mean he was just a crusher crusher.
Yeah.
He was like a rob came and all these
guys,
they start what they did,
what they lit.
The reason was they started winning
fights in Thailand was because they had
better hands tied to hence and the kicks
together and they didn't do that in
Thailand yet.
Predominantly only kicking,
kicking in a lot of clenching.
And then you had like a rob rob came on
or what is the greatest kick boxers
ever,
you know,
and then you suddenly,
that's the technical version.
The more smooth one probably he had the
slow twitch fibers,
you know,
because he,
don't get me wrong,
he knock you out with every punch.
but then you had ramon dekkers was the
explosive guy that he had that technique
and he,
he added the explosiveness to.
It's pricelessness too.
She's just crazy power.
You know,
when he fights bomb the first time,
you know,
and he hits him with 26 punchy,
you gotta to see the shots that he was
never a 200 fights.
Never been knocked out in his life.
He was the first guy to do that.
And they just see after the five wendy's
down,
the whole place is quiet.
Nobody moves.
And then rob cameron jumps in the ring
with the dutch flag
pulled out.
Fight up man.
rob k not robbed him.
And ramon dekkers versus kolbe and kolbe
on luck.
Some toy tongue,
right.
Is that how you say it?
Just,
it just,
I,
oh,
it's been a with these bullies names.
She knows.
It's not going to say okay at golden his
first bam thai names are pretty crazy.
The amount of adverbs and adjectives
they have in their fucking like
whatever.
Strange.
Yeah,
the,
the uh,
the amount of consonance all just lumped
in together and all these crazy names
period is.
But,
but just to see What kind of barriers
that hook,
the kick bond.
Oh yeah.
Leave that left hook,
man.
What rob came in.
The difference between rob came in.
Here we go.
Yeah,
here it is.
Rob came and was just more technical.
He didn't take as many chances.
You didn't get hit as much.
He was very smart and very technical
when he fought and he's a great trainer
to know.
Rob cayman was really one of the guys
who was responsible for brandon vera
early in his career.
You know when brandon vera was knocking
everybody dead in the ufc early in his
career,
he was training with rob came in and
when he stopped training with rob came
in is when things started lIke not going
so well For them.
Oh,
this is caLled bond.
This is a slow motion dishes.
They show cobana no knocking people out
I think so they know who co bonus and
they called them the buffalo hat.
That was his nickname because he never
went down while he had a giant head.
And then this is,
see if they can show.
So go slow motion.
Maybe that says slowmo honestly,
that there we go.
Now they're actually fighting.
This is going to be so crazy the way he
gives him the extra punch lights,
an event,
you'll see it.
So ramon,
like most of the time,
fought south paws that what it was.
No,
he didn't get the docs don't fault both.
So most of the time when he fights
different is because he hAs an injury,
like you said.
Oh,
this is lawrence skin,
a kenshin,
uh,
who's an amazing,
like analyst.
He does a fantastic job of breaking down
fights.
HiS fight breakdowns are amazing,
but he does a lot of it in slow motion
to show technique.
So see if he could find just the actual
fight instead of that video because when
you should definitely,
if you're a fan of striking and you want
to understand it a little bit of a
little bit better watch lawrence and
stuff.
What is the,
uh,
his Youtube channel.
Lawrence's youtube channel because she
kept him some props.
Just his nAme.
Lawrence pension.
He's amazing.
Lawrence is amazing.
He does such a great job of breaking
down fights.
His videos are incredible.
And um,
he really deserves a lot of credit for
that.
I love watching his breakdowns,
especially tie.
He loves it.
A lot of moitai moitai breakdown.
So here's the actual fight itself,
man.
these are the,
these are like in a lot of ways,
like unprecedented times because that
ties back in those days we,
we were used to karate and we were used
to a pka kickboxing.
Yeah,
10 gigs.
Wok to the.
At first I didn't know.
And then when westerners started going
over to Thailand and competing as the
ties,
we've started seeing what high level
more time they had and they're kicking
technique.
And especially the low kicks was just
devastating.
That was the first,
the,
the american championship when they
came,
when they lost it was low kicks,
gamble.
We're making sure weren't ready for
rufus.
Went and fought.
And it's kind of funny because duke
roufus talks about,
he kind of laughs about it now that they
were saying when,
when his brother got fucked up,
I forget who his brother fought,
but he got lit up with leg kicks and
stopped.
And duke was like,
well,
there's not a lot of techniques of that.
And you know,
I don't think there's much doesn't take
much talent,
but
they didn't know.
You said it's god.
This is it.
Ramon dekkers in his prime.
I know the coupon gets up the finishing
point she's going to give,
which went to god the fucking hands.
How tough was coal bon looking at me?
He's out on his feet.
He's walking forward.
They've given him a standing eight count
the last right hand.
What's the into?
This is going to be so bad as.
It's amazing.
How much bond could take the book.
Oh,
that's it.
Watch.
Look at the audience.
Just only dutch guys.
Everybody's quiet and then you see a
cayman coming in,
but it's going to get the flag
man.
How fucking tough was cold bond too,
to take those shots.
A lot of people lost a lot of money
there.
I mean there's not a whole lot of people
on the planet.
His weight,
they would have taken those punches as
many as he took clean to the face and
there we saw the flag
and,
and ramon dekkers was just teeing off
full power.
I mean,
winging those shots in on them too,
man.
You know,
there's such a scary guy.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
Glory days while he's up there now with
gavin.
So they're having a blast.
Yeah.
He,
he died young as well.
Yeah.
A heart attack while he was riding his
bike.
His bike.
Yep.
What was that?
Do they know what happened?
No,
the first started,
maybe it fell,
but it was,
it was just hard.
And he's also,
because we all been crazy every week.
We all liked going push,
pushing limits,
you know,
we were drinking with everything in it,
but he was stoli like a year.
Nothing was started cycling and I knew,
you know,
once he starts showing and he loved
cycling,
I'm was going to go 50 miles an hour.
I know he's going to because that's how,
who he is.
He can't stop being the best at
everything he does.
So I thought it wasn't just riding his
bike,
be going crazy with wisco.
Yeah,
that's his attitude was pushing animal
such an animal.
He probably pushed himself to his heart
broke.
And also when you see him,
you know,
all the elder punishment,
he got into tae with all the cuts on his
forehead
looks really bad.
So when you're looking at it,
you go,
oh yeah,
that's.
Yeah,
I want that.
Well,
I remember when he fought duane ludwig
towards the end of his career.
I mean deep into.
I mean his face was flattened out is
massive scar tissue all over his eyes.
His nose was flattened out.
I mean he took a lot of fun.
I don't think anybody's face changed
more than vandalized though,
that his face got flattened.
I mean,
you look at vandelay during the old
valley,
tudo days and then vandelay towards the
end and pride.
I mean it changed his face,
didn't they do surgery?
But the post,
like nick diaz did,
you know,
to make a flutter in the ufc.
They did not only did that,
they took cartilage out of his rib and
reconstructed his nose and vandal.
He had his nose made big so that he
could get more.
Aaron.
He looked crazy because his nose looks
very different than it used to look
like.
I remember the first time I saw him was
on the way.
He was like for the weigh ins.
He wasn't fighting.
He was with someone else and he came up
the stage and I didn't know who the fuck
it was
scary and someone said,
that's vandelay.
And I went,
what?
What?
Because he had just gotten the surgery
so his face was pulled tight.
His eyebrows were pulled tight and his
nose was big.
It was like he had his nose made much
larger with a big piece of cartilage so
that they can take punches.
Oh yeah.
That's the same at the stupid air.
So you know those golden flowers.
I sucked them out three times a day.
You've got to step through it and you
didn't need a big syringe and a large
needle because I do not want to have
those areas and they go,
oh no.
The considerate trophies.
I go,
okay,
good for you.
For me,
I always worry your guards.
I have a little tiny pieces of it here
and they always wore at your garden.
It's just,
it's just not smart.
It's it.
It affects your hearing,
like it looks cool,
but it affects the way,
the reason that is designed that way.
So the sound echoes off the outside of
the year and you could hear better.
Like if you take your ear like folks who
don't have cauliflower ear,
take your ear,
go over the top of your ear and bend it
down.
That's what those guys are hearing like
all the time.
Like randy,
randy can't even use iphone earpods.
Those.
You're,
you're,
they can put them in things.
So yeah,
walk around with a bluetooth and I said,
how can you listen to.
It's not even an air will.
Randy told me to his,
you know what happens with what it is is
calcification.
So when your,
your brakes and bleeds,
if you don't drain it,
it actually turns the calcium.
Turns out.
So it's like a bone.
So what randy would do is get on top of
guys and grind his ear into their
eyeball.
He would get his ear like when he's
taking guys down,
he was shoved his ear.
Right?
It's like he had a rock.
Something very wrong with this guy
looking at.
Yeah.
Well,
and just to let people know at home it
really tiny surgery can fix this right
away.
I mean,
they can fix this in,
in,
in 10 minutes.
Now.
One of eddie bravo's black belts.
Brent,
He had it done.
He had his,
uh,
his ear caught and then they pulled back
and they pull the stuff out.
But it can,
it can get very dangerous too.
You can get some infections in there.
Like you remember dave?
Tarell?
Yeah.
Dave had his ear fucking removed because
he had such.
He had his ear removed.
They had to cauterize the inside of his
ear because infections were so bad that
it was like it was fucking with his
equilibrium.
His balance was off.
Like the whole inside of his ear was
just pus and infections.
Kimbo against thompson.
James thompson fight when he,
they called it like a satellite was hits
it that you see.
He went in there with.
I mean,
he didn't,
not only did he not drain it,
it was like a recent blood.
It was like,
it was like he had a mouse living in his
ear.
It was big.
Oh,
that was nasty.
And then he hits it.
That was nastia splitter.
Well,
probably no one's worse than jessica.
I versus a laura.
Laura smith.
Was it Laura Smith?
What was her name?
the gunshot.
Leslie leslie smith.
Thank you.
And jessica.
I hits her an ear and you see the blood
up in the air from her ear was insane.
It will be crazy if she hits.
She used the blood flying and I go try
to catch it to this great to see it
right there.
And half of her ear was hanging off her
head.
And by the way,
how tough is leslie smith?
Because leslie smith was mad that they
stopped the fight.
She had a fucking hole that you could
see her brain.
Oh,
I.
I'm always been a big fan of less,
but listen nickname.
Right.
The gunslinger or something.
That's a.
It's a.
What is her nickname?
Something like a western.
I dunno.
Yeah,
It fits her Because she's tough.
And jessica to start targeting that one
spot over and over again.
Oh,
it's disgusting.
That was a.
That was a nasty ear,
man.
That was a bad.
I never got that.
People use.
I will be too nice at that moment.
I won't.
I won't hit that day or I guess people
go like,
oh,
that's a clint eastwood.
I thought a bike.
Cynthia is towards
the peacemaker.
Well,
woman's mma is really heating up right
now.
Right?
With joanna.
You and judge.
Check a lover.
Who's the.
Who's the guy?
Yeah,
she's fun,
man.
That chick is wild.
She breaks her hands a lot too.
Unfortunately.
She broke her hands in to ufc fight so
far in the first.
The first ones,
but I just the last five.
yeah,
that's why she couldn't finish.
He said.
Yeah,
total edible.
Yeah.
She's tough as shit level show.
The way she gets in,
in,
in the,
in their head,
you know,
the way his story gets low and looks at
it from below.
She's dangerous.
She's dangerous,
but claudia good data is a fucking beast
to.
Yup.
That's a great fight.
And they're going to coach alongside
each other.
They're gonna coach on the ultimate
fighter and then they're gonna fight and
they're gonna fight the day,
the big july ufc 200 card.
Oh,
well yeah.
So they're going to have the finalS on
friday where the ultimate fighter finals
and then they're going to fight for the
title.
You want to young jay,
check and logic a day,
and then they're going to have the big
200 card,
which they don't even know exactly who'S
going to fight in the 200 card.
And I mean that's july.
So a lot depends on conor mcgregor
versus dos anjos no,
no,
this just for joanna.
I want to see the ultimate fighter.
Now you know,
because that.
That's going to be interesting because
they're a personality I think.
Oh yeah.
It's going to make it.
Well,
a good data.
Also an animal.
Well,
they fought and it was a split decision
very close right away.
The codella luke's,
right?
Her body.
Yes.
Like in a,
also like a machine.
Very good moitai too,
but really good ground game.
Yep.
So the question is,
what is she gonna be able to get it to
the ground because joanna hurt her in
the first round,
knocked her down and won that round.
But a lot of people thought that
claudIa,
I might've won the second and third.
So it was a very close fight,
very close fight,
very controversial and very tightly
disputed fight.
So I think the rematch can be very
exciting.
I'm looking forward to that.
Who said chika work with for wrestling?
That's a good question.
I don't know who her wrestling coaches,
but I think she does a lot of her work
in Poland,
you know,
because she lives in Poland.
So,
I mean there's so many good european
wrestling coaches,
you know,
europe and wrestling,
there's a lot of great,
uh,
like especially,
they,
they bring a lot of eastern bloc
wrestlers,
a lot of the russian wrestlers.
Like that's what how george st pierre
got so good,
the russian nationals who are training
up in montreal and he goes,
oh,
so technical to,
you know,
those guys,
the russian style of wrestling is so
technical,
so drill oriented,
you know,
there's so many really high level.
I mean look at what's happening now in
the ufc with all these sambo guYs.
These high level grapplers like,
um,
well first of all you've got a habib,
norma madoff who,
who's one of the best in the lightweight
division,
but he's another one that has a hard
time staying healthy,
you know,
but,
but you,
you think it's a training or you think
it's just the person who knows,
you know,
it could be both.
You know what I mean?
He's such a fucking animal.
You see the way he fights,
you got to think he trains that way.
The way he fights it.
Just so grinding.
He so fucking attacking and relentless
like a badger,
you know?
So who knows?
Yeah,
I,
I always,
I wish I was guilty of that as well.
I trained really hood like,
but what I hear stories I hear fight or
saying,
oh,
we go like on fridays we spar like 70
percent and I go in and they said no,
that's it.
I say that's just,
that's it for sparring.
Yeah.
Oh wow.
And they always ask,
oh,
so how many times she did it after your
workout?
Because that's what we're gonna do you
know if we're going to try to.
I'll try to hurt your legs while I.
If you have to fight,
I won't be in your body.
I will go with kickstarter.
I expect that most show to go hard with
me and the hats,
you know?
Yeah,
of course.
We watch out for the head.
We don't knock each other out too much.
Too much,
too much because it happens as well,
right?
It's inevitable,
but that's why.
But I didn't fight for seven years.
When I did that,
2000,
six,
five,
I felt great to share no ring rust.
I said no,
because we're doing it two times a day.
We're training,
we're training,
you know,
and if you're used to it is the same as
a fight.
Even if they go hard,
that's a fight.
Yeah.
Well it's very similar if you train like
that.
Some people feel like that's one of the
ideas behind hard training is that when
you train hard,
you fight hard and it becomes normal.
But then other people think,
well you really should just train
technical,
like a lot of the ties.
Do they train more technical and more
light wIth their sparring.
The hard work is all pad work in bag
work.
So there's people that think like that's
the way to save yourself.
Wonderboy says that.
He says he spars very light now because
he wants to preserve his chin,
wants to preserve hIs head.
He's like,
he saves the,
the hard work for the bag and for
fights.
I used to,
to in a lot with my buddy amir,
amir,
perhaps the navy seal guy from Israel.
And um,
he,
um,
he's the one guy who could hang with me
and I mean stemming noise because I will
not go my way,
but we will go hot.
People who see us,
they think without a control,
but it's not at all.
So it's also about who you train with.
If one day your,
your steady sparring partner is sick and
somebody else pops up or you don't know
that guy and that guy tries to make a
name for himself,
you know,
that's when you get the injuries.
But I truly believe in going hArd.
How many times do you see?
It really angers me if I see guys in a
clinch needing other people and they
need them.
Like they need training,
they just lift their legs.
Nobody gives a real neat look at joanna
when she makes sydney different story or
alister explode in there.
Yeah,
to have a sticker on a nice to the
thighs and it's not going to do anything
if you do it like that.
right?
If you do one hard one,
it's worse than a low kick because they
don't expect it.
The muscles relax.
He goes straight through,
but nobody doeS it.
So yeah,
there's a few.
And we were talking about it one percent
of the fighters,
but isn't it though,
like all techniques,
like some guys just aren't that good at
certain techniques,
they just don't have the kind of pop
like you'll see guys throw kicks and
this is nothing to them.
And it's not that they're not trying as
they don't have the looseness of the
hips,
they don't have that sort of snap into
the keg,
no emotional time.
It's just technique.
If he,
if you train your legs and you put like
10 pound ankle weights and you just
start throwing knees from zero,
don't,
don't make it.
Then a bouncing lake,
um,
sit ups,
I can do a thousand sit ups as long as I
use momentum to get back up.
That's the problem with a lot of guys
do.
They do the knees.
It's all momentum standstill,
xplode standstill,
explode.
And a trick also with nis is to move
your hips away from your partner
statements with a straight punch.
The longer than he is on its way,
the more power it's going to have.
And these guys,
they don't,
they,
they actually,
they teach.
Throw your hips in with the needs of the
body is the dumbest thing to do.
It's like me giving you a straight punch
and closing the distance.
I'm jamming myself.
You don't want to do that.
Free it up.
let the hip flexor do the work.
And at the moment you connect.
Yeah,
that's when you want to push your weight
in.
But a lot of guys don't do it like that.
They just need like they do in training.
Inspiring.
Do you get frustrated when.
I mean obviously there's some very high
level training going on an mma,
some very high level training,
but there's also some training where you
see these guys like they're just not
really prepared correctly.
Well if kicking inTo bowls and the
inside low kick a night,
90 percent of when it happens,
it's just because the guy doesn't know
how to get because he's kicking me,
kicking up his right foot.
If he gets with a leftist,
rightfully his toes,
I guarantee you,
pointing straight to the opponent.
What they need to do is open that foot
letter,
toes point to the side,
and then the angle is much easier to
kick.
You will never have that problem.
These are just guys who Don't know how
to kick and that's why to kick into
pills.
Well,
it's interesting because there's that
kick to the balls of so much more common
in mma than it is in more tie in glory
because they know exactly that going
kick.
You know,
we were taLking about gloria getting
before the podcast started.
We're talking about glory.
Getting picked up by fight past glory
right now is so good.
there's so much high level kickbox and
talent in the world and now that you
know,
glory picked up.
It'S showtime and k ones not really
around anymore.
I mean glories the game is the game.
That's it.
He got the best guys on the planet now.
You know goco saki,
even.
Yeah.
He got injured.
No,
but I don't know.
I don't know.
I just found out,
you know,
mara told me because he was gonna maybe
do that show.
I think maybe now it's ron crook falling
in for him,
but I'm saki.
That's,
that's the guy was like tyson.
And this what I teach a lot,
double rides,
double left punches,
you know,
everybody has a pattern.
Um,
the fight that really upset me is
packeo.
Ken's mayweather.
Re veterans hanging against the ropes.
I was just unloading,
but everYthing is left,
right,
left,
right now.
If you think of Mike Tyson suddenly
throws in the left upper god liver shut
or spleen.
Write up like a double right?
Double left.
You mix that into a pattern because if
you throw a boxer in the corner and you
start unloading on him with right,
left,
right,
left punch veteran,
they just punch.
Yeah,
but if you go left,
right,
left,
left bubble,
and you changed the second punch as
well,
like a three shot with a left hook,
and then you go to the body.
Well,
keep looking in his eyes or a left
uppercut.
Change the angle of the punch,
but use the same arm.
That's when you get really effective and
you see it as in boxing and thai boxing.
Everybody who does it is really
effective at it.
Yet he didn't do it.
They got paid $80,000,000 in
$180,000,000.
You would expect to do that.
Yeah.
I had a shoulder injury that doesn't
prevent them from touring.
A double left.
Our double right.
Mike dyson,
spleen might up bucket.
I think you know,
six out guys.
I would like to bang,
bang over unusual patterns.
Yep.
That's it.
Yeah.
Did you ever see the uh,
well john wayne has got fucking amazing
highlight
reel,
but one of them on my instagram page the
other day where he hits this guy with
seven upper cuts in a row with the right
side is bad.
Bang,
bang,
bang.
Like you can't prepare.
You don't know the guy's going to do
that.
I do this yesterday.
My class double right up at gun left.
People don't know double lift.
I had to hector pena.
He had three left upper cuts and the
second,
the third one,
the guy fell already down.
He hit him on the way down is three
leftover.
Here's the deal,
john wayne par highlight.
I love this highlight.
He said
he's an animal.
If one is good,
two is better.
John wayne par is a wild mother.
Really a great guy.
total edible.
He also came up with that striking
organization where he lives with mom.
Vague loss pretty much,
right?
It's his tie.
I'd never got anybody who doesn't do
that or why they don't do that here.
well they should and maybe he can bring
it to the United States,
but you know,
what he wanted to do is have like a
cage.
Like he likes the cage,
he likes the fact that you're trapped in
there and he likes the small gloves.
So it was like,
let's just do listen.
Fuck.
The ground game was just strike like
this.
I love a guy like that.
He's a wild guy.
He's fun.
Have you ever seen the pictures of his
face?
Like how many times he's been stitched
up?
Oh no.
I can only imagine.
There's a picture of John William
[inaudible] face after one of his fights
were.
His entire face is like a roadmap of
stitches.
It's fucking crazy.
Like see if you could find that picture
because it's one of those pictures.
You just,
you just look at it.
You start shaking your head and
blinking.
Like what the fuck?
His whole face is patched together.
Look at,
look at this photograph.
Look at this.
Oh,
jesus christ.
Real.
Yes.
That is the craziest thing.
It's one fight.
One fight.
His entire face.
A thai guy.
Yeah.
He got the shit elbowed out of them.
Wow.
It's such an insane photo.
He's other face.
He's over 300 stitches in his face.
300.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well eddie.
Well the ears are still good.
At least it doesn't have the color left.
one's been hit there as well from shots.
Yeah.
Not really from grappling.
He fought one mma fight,
but you know,
he's just never really trained.
Grappling.
IT's not really his thing.
You know,
put fucking has moitai goes.
I trained with him.
I got a chance to work out with him and
learn some techniques from everything he
throws is with power.
The way he throws a leg,
he pulls the right hand back as he
throws that jab,
he doesn't just jab like a boxer would
throw,
jab,
the way he jabs.
He's like pulling back the right and
stepping for got
everything he throws is designed to kill
you.
That's been,
that's been my my thing also.
I like it like that.
Everything you throw make them.
When you said in the beginning I kicked
somebody and you see their faces and I
don't care if they block it.
I jusT kick as hard as I can on the
defense just to get inside their heads
that they know that you better blog this
kick because next time if you're not
blogging it,
you're gonna have it's gonna be a
problem,
you know,
and then start breaking your
opponent down.
Mentally hit him,
hold the hands up high.
Just hit as hard as you can under.
Hence a lot of guys don't do that.
They truly believed that this is enough
defense for like a,
a right hook.
It's not.
It's like me putting on a helmet.
I say this in seminars at seminars to,
okay,
imagine I would tape a focus mit to my
face and you can give me a straight
punch or a hook.
You think I go down and everybody goes,
yeah,
of course you're going to go down.
I said,
so why is everybody doing this?
You make yourself one with your head.
I'm just going to hit your hands as hard
as I can.
You will still go down,
you know,
but what happens in the mind of a
fighter,
as soon as I hit you and I see your hand
going up,
automatically I let my power off because
it's like,
oh,
it's it's defendant.
What if you just don't care or closed
line?
And like I said in the beginning,
it'll go straight through.
Yeah,
well you started throwing kicks in the
pancrase days.
I remember,
you know,
because I came from a kicking
background,
there was not that many good kickers in
mma before maury smith for conan.
We really didn't see that many head kick
kaos in mma and especially against a
black belt when maurice fought conan
soviet era.
I mean there's a first time that was in
um,
public.
No,
no,
it was in that other one.
It wasn't that john pretty organization,
wasn't it like
extreme fighting?
Yeah.
Extreme files.
And that was the first time I was like,
oh,
okay,
now we're finally seeing a guy who could
throw some kicks in mma,
but with the first time really was you
in pancreas because you,
they make,
you wear those crazy boots you had like
wrestling shoes on with a big boot shin,
shin thing.
Yeah.
But you still at slam that kick into
their arms and just see like nobody
wants to hold pads for a guy like that.
no,
forget about like getting it on your raw
arm,
but you know,
it's,
it's a great way to go in,
into a fight because you know,
you can,
you're capable of doIng that.
Yeah.
So you only have to connect,
you know,
and if you know that joanie,
you have to connect,
just wait and connect.
And I also,
I'm not that guy who likes to get hit,
you know,
I don't mind,
but I'm,
I wrote a nut so I just use movement,
you know,
and then uh,
and then just explode at moments that
you need to explode.
How many finders you training right now?
Do you train any active guys?
No,
you,
I,
I train a few guys at my gym,
but I've been traveling a lot now so,
uh,
the coaches that I have at my gym or
training them,
but we got a one,
three,
three pros and then a bunch of amateur
guys.
So you're stIll doing inside mma with
ken kenny and um,
you do world series of fighting still
wheelchairs a fight.
Actually this weekend coming up on a
saturday this saturday on nbc isn't
really nice.
More osis funding again.
He's very talented.
His footwork to.
That's the guy that people sleep on.
Yup.
Yeah.
They don't really realize how talented
that guy's in.
It's unfortunate that world series of
fighting is not getting as much
attention as it deserves.
Yeah.
Well,
there's a lot of mma.
I know it's very hard to pull eyeballs
to it.
It's a,
but it's the with gloria.
Gloria doesn't have the eyeballs,
which blows me away because if there's
something exciting,
you know,
gore,
it's a gloria event in that just
engaging kid to.
Oh,
what an animal.
A fucking sad.
She's a fun,
fun,
fun to watch.
I,
you know,
he should tone a little down,
loa say,
but,
you know,
maybe it's just fight style and he just
wants to go because sometimes he gets
hit hard and I think eventually we had,
there were clay guida or you know,
like fighters.
Eventually it's going to be who's going
to give.
Yeah.
You can only get hit hard and just walk
through things so much until eventually
your body doesn't cooperate anymore.
And then most of the time,
once that happens,
it's going to happen a lot.
So there's a lot of crazy shit going on
right now in mma.
I'm the big one.
To me,
the one that I'm most excited about is
March 5th.
Conor mcgregor versus those.
That is a fucking crazy fight.
First of all,
who the hell has ever been like connor?
Yep,
well I mean the best shit talker of all
time.
Hilarious.
I,
I'm,
I'm in love with that guy.
I love him.
I love everything about him.
We had him on his show.
He's funny as you know,
everything he does.
Every speech he does,
it's different.
It's not like he's repeating everything
I do,
like I do an interview before and it's
about,
let's say your movie,
you know,
you,
you say the same thing over and over
again,
but he doesn't know,
you know,
and he doesn't really use profanity as
well,
so it keeps it clean,
but very encouraging.
Yeah,
you can use it on television was so
great.
You know.
And then how old chapo shirt.
Oh,
how crazy is he who does that?
But to see,
but he's making gets in everybody's
head.
That's why he beat the.
Although you could tell,
you could simply tell.
Everybody can say,
oh no,
I'm,
I'm used to that.
I will put a street over or rafael dos
anjos says that also.
I said,
eventually it's gonna come through,
you know,
you gotta start doing something back.
He was a few fun things that you always
can do is not engaging him.
I liked the way dos sandra says
handling.
He's just letting him talk and he's
like,
when we find this one I'm out,
or I know he's just like solid and
stoic.
I think he's also learning the lesson of
how although sorta got rattled and he's
not going to get route.
I think told sandra is a different guy
is a.
He's even doing the chapel posed,
shaking hands and sean penn and that
fixture,
so fucking crazy.
I love him.
God,
that guy's fucking awesome.
It's hilarious and he can flock in fire
fights.
Get great.
Reflects this.
I mean it's timing is really good.
He's using his reach really well and the
way for us to,
as a hobby.
He described his lefthand for us to
hobby,
by the way,
did an amazing breakdown.
If you're listening to this,
go to youtube for rasa hobby,
who I in my mind is one of the true
great masters of video.
He does an amazing breakdown of this
fight,
but the way he describes ca connor,
he's like,
he's got the touch of death that left
hand and it's true.
He just lights guys up at that left
hand.
Plus it's a laser guided,
you know,
it's,
it's on target.
It's not just.
He just doesn't hit the head.
Hit your jaw.
Yeah.
He's so
great timing,
so accurate and so and so beautiful with
his footwork.
The way slid out of the way of all those
advanced and just drop that left hand
in.
Just,
you know,
rda is this guy,
in the beginning I go always under the
radar.
Right.
And some of these,
boom,
he's there and he's just beating
everybody.
I mean,
I had ever expected that it was a
monster.
He really is.
Well,
a lot of what's going on to his.
His conditioning is off the charts.
Was working with nick curse on who's one
of the disciples of marinovich and
they've got him doing these crazy
explosive plyometric drills and all
these footwork drills and have you ever
seen his training routine?
You're realIzing they got a fucking
oxygen mask on him and he's throwing
body shots on the bag.
It's all this incredible,
brutal breakdown for for strength and
conditioning so that he could really go
five rounds like that.
There's no such thing as having enough
seminar.
That's what I always tell everybody.
No such thing.
Yeah.
You got to go all the way.
That's why I trained so hard because I
don't want to have that.
I had to experience in thai boxing one
time when I run out of gas.
It's not fun and especially in you no
longer around and with an opponent
seeing you know,
is he getting tired now?
They get wings,
you know,
they turn it on and you're in a bad spot
there.
Yeah.
It's the worst thing in the worlD to see
an opponent notice that you're tired and
he's not.
He's coming after you and he starts
dropping low kicks on you and punching
you in the face and you can't do
anything.
Your Body's not cooperating and they get
worse because then your breathing starts
going wrong.
The breathing patterns not too relaxed
anymore.
You have to stop flexing because the
punches are coming.
I'll take your stamina even more away.
Everything goes down.
Open.
Stamina is a weapon.
It really is.
I mean,
look at nick diaz who was a guy who
fought so many guys and outwork them.
I mean the frank shamrock five's a
perfect example that fight.
He,
he just kept popping them with punches
like 50 percent punches,
but he's hitting him and he can't
breathe because when,
when I punched persons punching you,
even if they're punching you and it's
not full blast,
you're still tightening up so you don't
get a chance to breathe.
And nick diaz doesn't get tired.
Does ultra marathons?
The fucking guy swam from alcatraz
twice.
He's in incredible shape.
He's done triathlons.
I don't know if he's done ultra
marathons,
probably take that back,
but swimming from alcatraz is a fucking
crazy endeavor.
Done it twice.
Well pedis for instance,
I thought he was never going to lose and
the only time she was losing what's
against guys with great stamina,
you know,
clay guida and an rda who just keep
pushing the fight,
you know,
and in the grappling grappling.
Yeah,
I think physically pedis is not strong
enough for those guys.
Guys like dos anjos that just put it to
them or eddie alvarez just put it to
them.
The physical,
like they turned it into one of those
grueling wrestling match.
I mean I think his take down defense is
pretty good and I think his grappling is
not bad.
I mean he won the title with an arm bar,
but I just think physically when it
comes to these grueling exchanges,
I just don't know if he's physically
strong to fight that fight with lego
dosantos yup.
Or even eddie alvarez and in that.
In that fight.
Yeah.
Well footwork.
Again,
they're gonna he needs,
he's going to need a lot of forward
laker mariah's.
He stopped staying down by.
Well he didn't even stop and just moves
out the way he moves out of the way the
lights guys up to and in his power to.
That's a big thing in pettis has a lot
of power to me.
I'm not counting pedis pedis could
easily come back and win the title again
and he's a monster,
but I,
I never expected him to lose.
I thought because she has this complete
package,
it was she a great striker,
the great submissions,
takedown defense.
I go,
okay,
this is the guy,
put them on a weedy bucks.
You put away ceremony even better and
more impressive than dos anjos.
Yeah.
That was the craziest dos anjos.
He hurts her one and battered him up
against the cage,
but I thought that the stoppage was so
weird because like looked at the referee
and he's telling the referee stopped the
fight and dosantos has serone sororities
turtled up and he's still covering up.
I don't know when a fight should be
stopped in that situation.
When a guy's guy gets hurt to the body
was obviously hurt,
but dos anjos is hitting them and
cowboys covering up.
Like when do you stop a fight?
Like if a guy's covering up and you're
hitting his arms and he's talking like
he's trying to get back up to his feet,
like when does a fight get stopped?
When is it okay?
Because some referees wouldn't have
stopped the fight.
Yep.
No,
you're right.
Here's a perfect example,
right?
Chris weidman versus luke rockhold.
When luke rockhold got on top of chrIs
weidman at the end of the round was
beating the fuck out of him.
I was saying they should stop that.
Like he's not defending him,
but like that's not the same as like the
cowboy cerrone dos anjos fight.
I'm like,
man,
that was a little bit of a more
controversial stuff because you're still
is a defense.
No,
they shouldn't.
They shouldn't stop the only one wIthout
coming in and do.
If he doesn't,
doesn't cover up.
he's going to get hit with a punch.
So he's got to cover up and when you're
covering up and the guys boom,
boom,
boom.
There's not a lot You can do.
Yeah.
If you got to put your hand down to get
up and if you put your hand down and get
up,
you're going to get tagged.
Yep.
So it's kind of,
it's,
it's almost like a guy can have a fight
stopped without you being in real
trouble.
Although cowboy was certainly in
Yup.
But it's,
it's a weird little kind of a.
It's up.
It's so subjective.
It's up to the referee to decide the
decision.
That's why I don't want to be a referee.
It's a very hard decision today.
It really is just never good.
Yeah.
Great.
But you did for the safety of the
photos.
If they don't,
you know,
drawn to go out and they don't defend
them.
I should've stopped right away if they
really,
because they don't.
That's why they're doing it.
Right.
I mean,
you,
you know how uh,
like a big jaw and he tells me that I,
I've seen him doing it against the
fighters,
into the dressing room.
He'll tell them,
do not come to me after the fight that
if you lay on the ground to the guy who
hit you and you're just bugging up,
I will stop the fight and he says it two
or three times.
Do not come to me after the fight and
complain about it because you know right
now improve your position and sometimes
you,
you don't see that.
I'm also,
it's for instance,
a guillotine attempt.
So or,
or you see guys who defend the
guillotine like you're standing still
and I go,
don't defend the galaxy.
And you know,
go for position,
make sure that you get close,
you hold a heads to make sure
he doesn't jump guard because if you
defend well,
look at that militate against henzel.
Gracie in the ifl use definitive did
yoga.
He jumped garth.
Now he's got them now.
Rhonda rousey against carmouche.
You know she's got a crazy crank on the,
on their head and instead of defending
what people say,
oh,
differently the defendant.
No,
no,
she didn't.
She's had to position.
She grabbed the foot,
feet unlocked to fit and she got out.
She took a chance that she took a chest
and that's what people should do on the
ground also.
They said to me,
yeah,
but if they hit you,
I said,
escape,
buck up,
move to this.
If you bulk up,
they're going to have to look for
balance.
Make sure they never sit on your chest,
push them always to your belly.
If you can push into your belly,
you hold a nice and you push yourself up
or it's same result is sitting on your
belly.
But you gotta go.
You gotta move how easy it is.
Is it for you if,
if somebody mounts you to go to put them
in,
at least to have god?
Well,
you got to.
It's real easy,
right?
I think a lot of guys don't train off
their back then.
It's the craziest thing.
It drives me nuts.
Get them into gartman y amount position.
It shouldn't even be happening.
Go to the side mount position when they
could stop you.
It's only when they put the stretch,
you out a hook,
their feet,
you know,
but then there's not a lot they can do
because she just stopped their arms.
So it's interesting when you see the
different levels of,
of their game off their back.
Like Brian Ortega,
have you been watching that guy?
Jesus fucking christ.
His triangles are good.
His guard game is so good and he's one
of those guys.
He's like a gold standard for how to
fight off your back.
Yeah.
When they get him on his back,
he is just that packing attacking you.
You're not going to get him stagnant
where he's just lying there waiting for
the referee to stand them back up.
That's when you've got that kind of a
ground game off your back.
It's A totally new dimension for your
opponents.
They're used to taking a guy down and
maybe throw in some body punches with
him.
You're fucking defense defending the
whole tags are up on your neck and you
got to try to pass her up and get outta
there.
That's the gold standard and that's what
everybody should aspire to,
to have that kind of a dangerous ground
game.
Yup.
That's why I thought,
um,
for instance,
uh,
Johnny Hendricks is a wonderful thing.
No,
no,
no.
Oh my god.
How could I forget him?
He was carlos condit,
the international bulk carrier.
I was gonna say.
Yeah.
I mean I thought a conduit honda because
he's constantly attacking underground,
you know?
And if somebody is on top of you and he
hit you once every what time?
That shouldn't count.
If destroy undefeated,
if it,
if it goes through a decision and nobody
get really hurt,
but the guy who's constantly attacking
is going to win the fight.
Right?
Okay.
Why so why doesn't that count on the
ground?
Just because it goes on top doesn't mean
he's winning.
No.
How about the fact that that's how you
want the title versus kevin rowlanD down
random?
Not even with submission,
that example,
but like,
man,
that was shook you down and you just
kept attacking from your back.
Yeah.
Mccarthy said later,
I didn't put them back on a fit because
boss was working from his bag.
That was the reason they didn't put us
back on the feet.
But you know,
if you have a gay guy,
psychologists content or what,
you saw a lot of pride,
also great
groundwork and a constantly attacking
and then they get rewarded for that
after the fight.
They actually win the fight and it
should be because people go,
yeah,
but the defense is no,
no.
It's not about the defense.
Same as the strike.
It's not about that.
It's about a guy who takes the chances
because we all know if you have somebody
in the guard,
you go for an arm bar as I possibility
there's going to be an assignment.
No,
that's a worse posItion for you.
So you're taking risks and if you're
willing to take those chris,
they should be rewarded.
Well,
how also like pride.
I like that 10 minute first round.
That was good.
It makes it,
makes it more strategical.
Yeah.
He really can't burn out in the
beginning.
That was the thing with bankers in the
beginning,
but 30 minute fights.
That's why the arts came on my hands
because that means holistic,
which is relaxed because I was such a
hothead in thai boxing like somebody
hits me,
god there might just knock them out,
you know,
and I go,
man,
these japanese guys are known for being
tough.
If this happens,
the first three minutes I get 27 more
minutes ago.
If I'm empty,
that's not a good thing.
So stay calm,
stay calm,
and you start to be more strategical.
So pancreas,
was there any rounds or was it just know
30 minutes at the end.
In the end there were a few under,
unlike the undercard for 10 minutes
fights,
but most of the time was,
everything was 15 minutes and the title
fights and the end was 30 in the
beginning the first year.
And a half minutes.
Three minutes.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's,
that's a real strategic fight.
I'm a fan of that though.
I liked that.
I liked that too.
But,
but you know,
and again,
if you look at some ufc fights where
they just lay la la,
then you know,
in the old days,
whoever without a standup and then it
becomes kind of boring.
But that was one of the things when I
moved to pancras always tell this story,
but when I saw my opponent,
he was 45 pounds heavier and I asked
when,
the way in was,
he says,
there's no way in we everybody fights,
everybody go out.
it's great.
Nice.
Well,
I was just bluffing of course.
And I go,
okay,
so how many months?
We got one round,
one round.
Awesome.
How many minutes?
Thirty.
You'd go.
Oh,
awesome.
When I look at my manager,
I could lose 30 minutes,
45 more pounds on me as opposed to a
three minute kickboxing for.
That's what I was thinking around,
you know,
boxing,
kickboxing.
Yep.
Yeah.
So yeah,
that opened my eyes a little bit there.
and you become more strategical.
That's a good thing.
Well,
it's also good for grapplers when they
work,
like say if you have a five minute fight
or a five minute round and you work for
four minutes and 30 seconds and get the
fight to the ground,
you only have 30 seconds to try to
secure a submission.
Whereas if you take god to ground a 10
minute fight in your format in 30
seconds,
now you have five minutes and 30 seconds
to try to finish him.
Which is a lot of time.
Yeah.
But you know this,
there's always the other side of the
middle of you know,
you,
you can say,
well they should have taken them down
sooner or are these guys and say,
yeah,
but I just need more work on the ground.
Well,
just go faster.
This is the game you after that they not
the other way around.
Yeah.
Well you could definitely look at it
that way.
What do you think about fabrice
overdoing,
returning against king?
I think it's a.
It's Going to be a great fight.
I think again for the.
Okay.
We know
that the Seminar Played a big factor is
huge,
but um,
for,
do man,
he's only been on an,
on an arrowed as going straight up
since.
Since pride.
Yeah.
I mean always that fight that he lost
against the allister,
eh,
really loose.
I think if you would count the punches
and kicks that alice,
I get it because I was afraid at the
time because I was at.
Ellis does a,
it was a big friend of mine at the time
and I go,
oh,
because for doom hidden more connected.
More on.
He blew his knee out to in that fight.
Yeah.
see,
so striking now with codero there,
they're working really well to get a say
with rda and everybody there,
they're doing just a phenomenal job or
was just what a great striking coach.
That guy.
Yeah.
He's done an amazing job.
Yeah,
because he's a,
he's an.
You could talk to the guy.
They barbecue together today.
You know,
he's there in your best interest.
That's duane ludwig.
Same guy tompkins.
All these guys.
There are all.
The way to.
I remember stories was sean,
we will come home partying five,
six in the morning.
He would go straight to as if it was the
day of the way in straight to the soul.
now with the guys putting them,
helping them focus mitts,
if they wanted to lose weight,
he never ever missed a beat,
you know,
and then like a dwayne has adults,
a lot of trainers out there,
but there's a whole bunch of trends,
you know,
as well as I do who don't have that.
Yeah.
Well you got to be completely obsessed
to be a great treat me.
That's what makes ludwig so good.
He's completely obsessed.
He is.
And that,
those.
I mean,
it's the same with a fighter.
It's the same with anything.
If you're not completely obsessed,
you're just not going to reach your
potential.
That's it.
You need to like it.
Also,
I was talking about that yesterday.
It's um,
you can have all the talent if you don't
like it,
if he hear fighters,
which blows my mind always when I hear
quintin french,
he says,
I hate training.
And I go,
wow,
I love training.
I want to get tired,
I want to try new stuff.
I always loved it till the end when I
got my tendonitis and everything started
hurting really,
really bad,
you know?
Then you can't even think straight
anymore.
That's when I stopped.
But before that,
I always loved it.
And if you love something,
you know,
same in school.
When you work at,
you know,
math lab,
I don't even math,
but you were good at the things that you
liked.
Biology.
I love biology.
Boom.
Ace,
you know,
it's,
it's all the things that you like.
You automatically do your best.
For example.
Yeah.
If you're a passionate person,
if you're passionate about what you're
pursuing,
you're going to do better than a person
who's just doing it as a job and clinton
has so much talent and unbelievable
power.
He's got a fantastic chin.
Yeah,
right.
Writer wrote up,
pops up,
right?
always.
Always.
When you talk about quinn is the first
and the arched even backwards.
Yeah.
He didn't go straight up.
He actually went a lIttle further and
then that was the most spectacular slam
kayo and the history of mma.
Ricardo arona had them locked up in a
triangle and quintin slammed him into
oblivion and headbutted him too,
on the way down.
I mean inadvertent headbutt,
but slammed them and then bought by then
his head slammed into him too.
Oh my god.
That was a horrific fight.
Ricardo ricardo never,
never recovered from that.
Well,
ricardo,
I read the cool story about kevin random
and he was talking a read on.
Sure,
doug,
that he said he just fought kevin and he
won.
He says for I wasn't addressing wound by
myself and in Japan was nobody there and
you know,
I was just aching and he said,
because I would just want to the most
important fight of my career.
And he said suddenly he sees his shadow
and he thinks it was gentleman.
So he automaticallY said at that time
everybody was fighting.
It was before or after.
It didn't really matter.
It was this fighting thing.
And randleman came in and he thought
there was going to be a fighter reynold
liftgate walked up to him and said,
dude,
great job.
Congratulations.
You know,
you're awesome.
And he blew me away.
He said it rIght away.
I saw the monster as a different person.
That's so hard now.
Also with random and uh,
you,
you know him.
Everybody who knows him is such a good
guy.
Yeah.
He was a great guy.
He was a really friendly,
happy go lucky guy.
It's so unfortunate,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know what happened with him.
And what happened with sean tompkins.
How did sean,
you know,
this was the saddest thing ever because
when I went to the funeral,
his,
um,
uh,
he was in a coffin and I didn't want to
see that.
I did that one time with a friend of
mine and I didn't like that.
So I said,
don't want to do it in his mother.
It was so sad,
man.
It's uh,
she came to me crying and she said,
oh,
he was in,
he was home and that weekend she was
going to tell him that he had to go to
the doctor because in the family that
runs in the family,
that they have enlarged hearts and he
needs to check that out.
And that was what was going down there.
He was no drugs,
no,
not because people start,
of course,
the conspiracy theories,
they didn't find anything,
find anything.
And the crazy thing was I talked the day
before we,
sean,
it was so weird because then you guys
announced it on uc.
It was.
I go,
whoa,
sean.
So I started.
I started googling,
but he,
it was so weird.
He texted me something and I thought for
some reason I thought,
oh,
he wants to talk to me because normally
we would text.
So I picked up the phone and I called
him and he was going out with a muscle
beach,
one of our friends that we'd call the
muscle beach and he was um,
he,
he muscle beach was drunk and he says,
by can't leave a man behind.
I'm going to stay with him,
you know,
I'm going to make sure he's going to be
okay.
Boom.
And he kept going and the problem that I
was reading about didn't even come up.
We start talking about everything.
It was great,
great diaries as part I love you,
you know that I really love you.
And then finally when we hang up,
he started texting,
you know that I love you,
tom.
The whole team tompkins loves you.
It was really weird.
He never did that.
And the next day he passed away.
So it was almost like he felt that it
was going to happen.
Wow.
Yeah.
Crazy.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
He was another guy that was really loved
by the guys that he trained those
relationships between trainers and
students,
trainers and fighters.
They're so important,
you know,
and it's so hard for a fighter to find
the right trainer,
the right train of the fits,
their personality.
Someone who's technical,
you know,
someone who has also that emotional
bond.
That's the thing,
does 100 percent commitment.
That's the thing.
And it was being a fighter.
It's soul sound cool.
And that's why a lot of guys don't make
it because they only want to look cool.
You know,
you don't really fight foot to fight.
Like once they fight a start fighting
for money,
you know,
don't do that.
Then it's going downhill.
Yeah.
But I needed a paycheck then don't
fight.
Find it,
find another job.
You need that commitment.
You need to be 100 percent emphasis.
Same with the trainers.
You know you can be off for a little bit
because this guy is going to go in the
ring or in a cage and you have to make
sure that he's going to stay safe.
Yeah.
When you see a fighter that's only
fighting for the paycheck,
it's very rarely works out,
which is very rarely.
We're not at a championship level,
you know?
I mean it miGht,
it might be okay at a journeyman level,
you might pull it off if you're tough
and you're Skilled,
but to beat the best guys,
you have to be obsessed.
Like the best guys are obsessed.
Yeah.
You want to be the best.
It's not about Payday.
I said,
that will come if you are the best,
the bay,
they will be better.
But focus on getting good at fighting
for yourself.
I always say,
you know,
don't put your family number one spot.
I understand you want to do that,
but you know,
once you start,
that means that you care.
Care care.
It's a very.
How you say it,
it's a selfish.
It should be selfish.
You should be.
I fight for me,
I don't care.
The way I explained it to my,
my,
my students is when they,
for instance,
they are nervous.
I say,
okay,
well let's,
let's take a step back.
Imagine your opponent now and you will
go in a room.
They loved the room and you guys going
to compete against each other.
Whoever wins,
it doesn't matter who wins.
When the door opens you,
both of you are not going to say who won
or lost.
Nobody's going to say,
do you really care if you lose at that
moment?
And he goes,
I know.
Yeah,
because.
No,
because yeah,
he's just a better fighter,
right?
I said,
so why do you care?
And then they start realizing,
ah,
it's because the people more,
but he might think this and he might
think this and see.
And that's why I always say fight for
yourself.
If you lose,
you give a joel,
you are always a winner.
It doesn't matter.
You know what?
Bad is not going all the way not using
all your potential and then lose.
Because you didn't do that,
that's something that after a fight
you're going to say,
oh man,
I could have gotten harder,
so why didn't you?
You know,
just leave it all out there and if you
leave it all out there,
there's no excuses and every other
fighter will really enjoy you winning or
losing.
How many fighters do you have?
Who,
who never became a champion,
but out here,
all the other fighters talking about
them,
she,
oh,
you fight him.
Oh dude,
that guy's crazy.
Yeah,
you better prepare now because it's
going to be a nightmare to fight that
guy.
You see?
That's what I think is the most
important.
If your peers like it,
the way you fight,
you're good.
You can't really lose.
Yeah.
worker guy like chocolate dell where he
has that incredible fan base because he
always fought with everything he had and
whether he lost by knockout or won
knockout,
people still loved him.
That's it.
Didn't lose a friend.
I always use chuck as an example and
that's.
And that's what every filenet tell my
students,
look at chocolate l,
I want you to be like that.
Leave it out there,
you know,
I just want you to listen to a little
bit more because if I would get in
chuck's head,
you know as soon as chuck hits somebody,
that's the same with benji radic day,
have one vision and that's the knockout,
and they forget about the rest defense
defense as say,
as soon as you hit somebody,
step back,
you're going to have some time.
Don't worry,
but you just Hit the head,
okay,
what is she going to protect?
No,
the head go for the body.
Do what crosses across to the body.
Nobody does it,
but do it as hard as you can.
Cross hook,
cross and a left hook to the head.
Bob,
bob,
boom.
Suddenly there's a lefty to that.
If you do the crossword cross,
it's a heart issue.
Can you will force them to block it,
which will open up for the left hook to
the head.
Same as with the body body ahead too.
Bloody bloody hood that go papa,
boom,
but the book I said,
yeah,
won't work like that.
You see a ricoh over hoover who does his
first mixed martial arts fight,
body,
boom,
and then the head.
Now bit the first two body shots.
If this guy doesn't block him,
he's going to get knocked out to the
body,
so now he respects your power.
That's what Mike Tyson did.
Spleen might,
upper gut.
He hits you so hard on the spleen that
the second time when he loads up or you,
he thinks he thinks it's going to be the
same punch,
but then he changed his angle to an
uppercut and his defenses here for the
screenshot.
If you do it powerful and heart,
it will work,
but if you do a buddy buddy hair bite
about it,
you know it's not gonna work.
Make everything count.
Yeah.
A lot of guys are trying to conserve
their energy.
You buy what I did after a workout,
I will put it back on the ground and it
would 30 minutes,
just go punching on a bag on the ground,
rolling into god giving you don't get
diane from there.
Come on guYs.
You don't really get that as nothing
there.
You can just go.
What is she going to do?
If he's on his back,
he's going to hit you back.
It's not going to hit you back.
You got to watch out for submissions,
but that's not get get you in,
in,
in trouble with your stamina.
Just go.
do you think now looking back when you
have these tendinitis and all these
other issues,
will you too tough for your body because
that what it is?
No,
I,
I.
What I think is that because I was so
sick as a kid that they,
they overflow.
We with cortisones.
I had so many cortisone,
so where was I?
I was,
I believe it was like 46 pills a day.
I took all.
I had really bad skin disease.
Yes,
I was.
So I had a lot of stuff that I took for
that and,
and the,
the tests they did on me,
I mean every week I had to go get 20
shots,
10 shots in each arm of what they would
do.
They would inject a little tiny bit of
where you are alert for and then to
hopefully it's like the flu vaccine.
They hopefully the body finds a way to
counter attack that,
but every time when to do that I'll be
sick and so I needed to recoup from that
the whole time and I think eventually
the cortisones because they're really
bad for the bones and attendance.
I think the court is really got my
tendinitis.
That's the reason.
That's interesting.
I never heard that before.
I've never heard of anybody having.
Well,
I never heard of anybody having that
many shots as a kid and then going on to
be a world championship fighter.
And the craziest thing is that when I
was young I did track and field and I
did it a pretty high level already
because I wanted it to be the next bruce
jenner at the time he was my hero.
You know wHat I mean?
That's how old I was.
He was the guy,
the decathlon guy.
That's what I wanted and I remember in
the end every time with javelin I had,
I already had that tendonitis and I
started recognizing that and I don't
know why it stayed away my entire career
and came back only at the end.
It's got to be the gods wiLl of god
telling me,
okay,
it was good fighter,
you know,
but um,
for some reason at the end it came back,
but I remember the pain from when I was
14 years old.
Do you have a desire to train like
championship level fighters because I
see you're talking about what guys don't
do correctly in which would like to see
them do,
like,
do you have this desire to get involved
with someone who's like really trying to
make a run at a title?
Oh,
you know,
I,
I enJoy things like for instance,
a rico roofer came in last week.
I love that.
Can,
you know?
Yeah,
because she's an athlete,
not just champion ethic gLory,
heavyweight champion,
amazing kickbox.
So when he said he was going to do mma,
I send them an email right away.
I said,
listen,
rico,
come to me.
Give me two hours of my time.
I'll,
I'll show you things.
They got to be very,
very helpful for you.
I'm not looking to be a coach because
they don't have the time for that.
I'm way too busy for that,
but I can get you in two hours.
I can get you a lot of inflammation.
Or like for instance,
John jones is a while back.
I was interviewing him and then he said
right away I was in albuquerque.
What are you going to do after this?
I said to my hotel is amanda,
you train me.
You sEe those guys who really want to
learn and they want you to start
learning and these guys listen and then
suddenly they start being more explosive
with kicking air and they go like,
this is,
this is crazy.
You know,
like sound effects.
I do a lot.
It had high pitch sound effects.
If you see somebody,
for instance,
if you do the focus mitts or you hit a
back,
you go pump,
pump,
pump pump one,
two,
three,
four like that punch.
And so if you just stop or you go in
your mind,
you go just do that.
And then just by doing that your body
automatically will adapt and will get
more explosive.
And he realized that.
He goes,
well,
and the next week or two weeks later,
we had greg jackson on the show and greg
tells me,
he says,
man,
what,
what have you been teaching and what do
you mean?
He says,
everybody makes these crazy son.
I said,
do they hit faster and harder?
And he goes,
yeah,
so,
you know,
so it really works to get in people's
heads.
Yeah.
And then if you have an athlete,
like an athlete like jones who will
listen to you.
Yeah,
that's gold that came to you.
Have a guy like that came to you and
said,
listen boss,
I want you to train me.
How is that something you would be
interested in doing?
There's going to be harder.
It depends whether you know the tv show
now to new podcast that elder to jim and
I met,
uh,
so much stuff.
The world shares of fighting that I
suddenly cannot do because then we got
to have 100 percent commitment.
You know,
I like a lot because I'm a very basic
guy.
Everything is basic,
the basics with me because everybody
forgets the basics.
So most of the time when when somebody
comes out,
like tim silvia,
a little while ago,
he came to my gym and he threw the left
hook wrong and I,
I tell them,
I said,
man,
just can be way harder.
And he started learning to throw the
hook without loading up and he wanted
his fight in 15 seconds with a left
hook.
He goes,
this is crazy.
It works that I enjoy to give them an
hour time and show them what they do
wrong.
And then if they actually listened to
it,
they realize why wait a minute,
I got more power.
You know,
I don't try to change the style.
I just showed them how you get maximum
power and if you mix it up between your
styles,
that's up to you.
But I see you have this incredible
passion about this guys and about
working on technique.
That's why I'm,
I'm curious like,
have you ever thought about like,
just going into training and.
YeaH,
no,
it's,
it's um,
it was too busy,
too busy,
but also,
um,
I don't now anymore,
but you know,
a lot of guys that you do over the
years,
so you put a lot,
you invest a lot of time and it doesn't
work,
it doesn't work out or they get a better
deal somewhere else and they just leave
you in a year.
She does with a lot of fighters,
you know,
and trainers that finally the trainer
has something or a manager and then they
just kick him to the side because I'm
going to save 10 percent here are going
to,
you know then.
but,
but then again,
those guys,
most of the time you see them losing,
you know,
because you broke the winning
combination.
If you have something.
My stretching routine and everybody
always says please post is because you
always talk about this.
My stretching routine is the same as it
was when,
uh,
when I started in [inaudible] 93,
well that's probably even before my
karate.
And I say,
you never changed it.
I said,
no,
I never change her.
Why wouldn't you do more access?
Because with that stretching routine,
I never had a problem.
Why would I change it and they've given
me a problem in training is he.
So now if I start adding things or
subtracting to certainly I get injured.
Just my own fault.
I had a winning combination.
Never always helped me.
Let's not break that.
Let's keep it the same.
And that's what everythinG.
Yeah.
It'S just.
I know that you have your gym and
thousand oaks.
YeP.
You know what's it callEd?
The westlake village.
Her boss woodlands elite.
Mma and you.
It's mostly a recreational peoples.
That is,
that's it?
Yeah.
Tuesdays,
thursdays.
I'm there at 6:00.
you know.
What kind of classes do you teach on?
Tuesdays is mostly striking.
[inaudible] only striking a thursdays I
start with ground but only like for 20
minutes because people want to work out
like the fight.
If I took five classes with the fighters
here,
we do a lot of growth to escapes and
reversals.
I always start like that.
That's how I trained.
I never started on my knees with
grappling.
I always lay on my back and I tell my
partner,
you can take any position you want to,
gordon.
So important is the most important thing
for a bad spot.
You put yourself in a bad spot and
figure out how to be comfortable in
those bad and work out of them all the
time.
That's it,
you know,
and the basics.
I had an a student one time coming over
to me and after class and he said,
boss,
you know what's funny?
I said,
tommy,
he says,
I've been working in now for three years
and you're teaching the same stuff.
I say,
yeah,
that is funny,
so you wouldn't have something more
funny.
And he goes,
yeah,
I say,
you're still not doing it,
and the reason I'm doing this is because
if people like you,
because you guys don't listen,
look around.
Yeah,
they don't.
They don't do it every bug to forget the
basics.
They all want to do Just spinning
becky's to the head,
the breakfast and the crazy elbows and
doing that.
Forget about basic stuff.
A simple one to how many times in boxing
you see a Knockout,
highest level of the planet who will do
the trick is just the timing and when
you throw it,
the timing,
the efficiency of the technique and
having it down where you own it.
Yep.
That's it.
Yeah.
So you're enjoying teaching.
You enjoy teaching couple times a week.
You enjoy doing that.
That's why I'm doing it.
And here's your striking class.
Were guys sparring in there or are they
mostly working on technique and it's all
technique and my classes you go like you
see girls in my class,
but I still like to double love double
right.
I can tell them any combination of
people who are watching diego,
like whoa,
what is this?
But they've been with me for awhile and
they're very technical,
you know,
and they,
they do really well with the striking.
Like yesterday again,
they were laughing about it.
She still goes,
always worked together.
Lora and dina,
that they're really good.
They're probably gonna listen to this
also,
but I said,
listen,
everybody throws a low kick at the end.
for instance,
a combination with a low kick,
but once you do that in a class at the
local,
they have their hands always down,
so I let him do it to me,
that combination.
And then just before they make kick,
I stretch my hand in front of the face
and I said,
I want everybody to do this because I
just walked around.
I said,
and as we're only three people from the
likes of 22 or 24 people,
there are,
we're doing it,
you know,
just keep your hands up,
just make,
you don't have to hit him.
Just be aware that I could be a punch,
you know,
keep your hands up.
And I walked over and they said,
where are we?
One of the three.
I say,
you know,
you were one of the three because you
guys are always doing it.
It's Just an a habit.
Make it good habit then don't lose the
habit.
But unfortunately a lot of guys lose it.
Now what is this podcast you're dealing
with?
Moral.
And that was one of the reasons why you
guys wanted to come in here together.
And like you said,
unfortunately moral got sick,
but you guys are doing a podcast
together.
We're doing a podcast or rutan and
brunello.
It's called a written and all.
And it's an itunes soundcloud.
It's everywhere.
We,
uh,
it's a,
it's a really fun.
People have no clue who morrow really
is.
You know,
they start now because the pick peas on
shore doc,
you know,
he's bipolar,
and he just goes up and down.
But the guy is a genius.
Like there's no prompt,
there's no nothing.
He just like kenny rice for instance,
same,
you know,
they have a brain,
you can ask him about a horse in the
1989 and you will know in the name of
it,
it is a moral.
And um,
and I told you the story before here
with a pro wrestling the gig that he now
has,
the people are raving about him
everywhere.
All,
even the pro wrestlers say,
did,
did a best guy I ever had.
And I told access stevie when once they
hire morrow.
And,
uh,
George Barnett to do the progressive new
Japan pro wrestling on tv.
Uh,
I told him,
I say,
you watch marvel was going to work for
the wwe.
After they hear him doing this,
he's going to get a job.
Mark my words while he's doing
everything now
doing that.
He's doing showtime boxing.
He did a bunch of glory fights or this
is your,
this is a landing page.
Beautiful.
Rutan rinella.
Written down the episodes.
Have you guys done so far?
Seven tomorrow.
Tomorrow's the seventh and tomorrow is
dedicated to kevin,
kevin randleman.
We got to have his wife on the Mark
Coleman on and we're going to talk about
his life and all the funny things.
I mean,
I got such a crazy stories with kevin.
I went to his wedding with my whole
family and it was so my family
destroyed.
I mean,
they want to go with us to the funeral.
Everything was uh,
uh,
you know,
it,
it was so sad.
The next day after the wedding,
we were all at the pool.
People laying down,
a little hung over,
you know,
and then suddenly there was a waterfall,
fully bald net and somebody started to
play volleyball and you know,
all these competitive guys there
suddenly this big themes on side with
the kits we're going to town and
everybody's wonderfully.
it was such a good time.
We had such a great time.
And then,
you know,
things like,
uh,
a thing like this happens.
It's a,
it's reallY upsetting.
It is,
it is.
He was,
he truly was a great guy.
I mean all my interactions with him
where he's always laughing and smiling
and hugging people.
And I remember I ran into kevin once we
were at the fights.
It was a smaller organization.
It was,
there was some fights going on in vegas
and kevin and I ran into each other at
the concession stand and he gives me
this big hug.
What's up man?
Man.
And then other people will come over and
it just fans,
fans coming.
Oh,
hey,
what's up kevin?
He was like,
hey,
how you doing man?
Hugging everybody and smile.
I'm like,
what?
I'm fucking jovial guy.
You know,
the first time I fought and we fought
and only met one time,
the fight before when he beat morris
smith or to make the picture indication
that became the poster later.
That was the only time I met him.
So now I'm in the hotel and I think
before the weigh ins and I'm waiting for
the elevator,
I'm by myself.
The elevator door opens and there is,
he is and he doesn't go.
It needs to be in.
So I get into the elevator close now
we're with the two of us in the elevator
and I'm looking,
but I can see his face in a mirror
reflection there and he already has a
smirk on his face.
No smoking.
And look at him.
And I go,
you know,
good luck tomorrow.
And he goes,
thank you.
He says,
you hit two and I got here,
thank you.
And I will look.
And he says,
if you keep your feet on the floor,
I promise you I won't take you down.
And I go,
really?
Okay.
He knows that
he gets notice.
Crazy guy.
So either if you keep your feet on the
floor.
So no kicks you crazy.
Crazy deal.
Yeah,
right.
Well that's strange
deal.
And so,
um,
so in the fight,
the fight starts and you'll see in the
fight was it starts,
the first thing he does,
he slept his thigh,
like kicked me.
Right.
So now I'm in.
So I go,
oh wait,
he's gonna think I gave him a low kick
so I've got to act like you give them a
lucky but gave him a front kick to the
face so if he will wants to time it to
take me down to get him square in the
face.
So I move,
I make a front kick and it goes just in
front of it and he's backing up.
I just miss him with the front kick to
the face and I see something in his eyes
and I pulled his day.
I couldn't have told this data while
after I couldn't figure what it was.
But in his mind he of course thought I
thought we said we're not going to kick,
you know,
but he did that slapping thing on his
thigh.
So it threw me off.
I thought,
oh no,
he wants me to kick him.
Okay.
So I guess that whole thing was not
real.
Let's start kicking,
you know,
but he got me because I kicked it,
took me down,
and then the only the front could get
missed.
He backed up a ca would have been fun.
Well,
there's always gamesmanship,
you know,
it's definitely a lot of that.
Oh,
I was talking to him the whole time,
the big john wooden in his book,
because I was literally.
People were bullying because laying on a
garden I say,
listen man.
I think friends would like,
it's better if he's
trying to negotiate
to go back on their feet,
you know,
I think
is a good guy.
Yeah.
He was a great guy.
He's a great guy too.
You know,
you guys were a part of the early days
of mma.
I mean,
you are one of the original pioneers of
this sport without a doubt.
I mean,
you're fighting with the osha course.
Soccer for the longest time I had that
poster.
There was a poster for the,
your announcing your fight with.
She said the world's greatest martial
artists boss route and that's how they
uh,
announced you.
I mean,
they were,
they were building you up because you
were like one of the first really elite
strikers to fight an mma,
you know?
Yeah.
They always,
they always said,
I said,
I said they messed up right there on the
post and they forgot to world looking.
The greatest looking marshall out is.
I told him that,
but they forgot it was a good time,
but dumb man.
Then when you look back on it,
I mean it's got to be pretty amazing the
time that you came along mean from
becoming a king of pancrase from
entering into the ufc and the ufc
heavyweight champion.
Like what,
what number was that?
Ufc 18 and 20.
Twenty.
I became the champ.
Wow.
Almost a 200.
No,
that's incredible.
It's crazy.
You know.
Then why it was such a great honor.
The hall of fame when they said the also
the pioneer section because the pioneer
section is a section that I will only
grow so far.
Yeah.
It will not show even in 2000 years from
now.
It just keeps going and whatever because
the new olympic,
but it doesn't matter.
We were always the ones that started it,
you know,
and that's a cool thing and it was a
cool.
I mean it's,
it's
crazy also that this is the oldest sport
in the world really fighting it is the
oldest form of competition,
but it's also the newest sport because
there's no sport from 1993,
which is when the ufc first started is
no sport from then that has exploded a
new sport that came along in 1993.
That's exploded.
And now in 2016,
I mean you have ronda rousey's on the
ellen show that we've talked about
today.
The economy,
greg or joel dos anjos fight is probably
gonna get close to $2 million pay per
view buys.
I mean,
that's going to be fucking crazy.
You're dealing with the sport that's
exploding,
just exploding now.
So it's,
it's so strange that this is this
combination of things.
The oldest sport is also the newest
sport and you from the time you started
competing,
you caught it like right at the
beginning of the wave.
Yeah.
That's it's,
it's really cool.
It's um,
it's an amazing feeling.
Many times fence ask,
wouldn't you want to be born like 20
years later?
I say,
no,
I'm perfectly happy right now and then
I'll show the way I wrapped it up.
I didn't lose him.
I lost 22.
Five is a great way to stop while I'm
ahead to every week I keep going.
She,
if I get home and what,
what vin?
One more,
you'll lose.
You win or you lose,
you know,
like that's not a great way to wrap up a
career.
Know of course injuries with me played a
factor,
you know,
maybe I got the injuries because they
said,
hey,
it's been going really well man.
You got to stop now in know because
you're getting older and you don't want
to admit that you get older because
she's still explosive and you still want
to do it.
Then you still train with guys.
When I came back,
I trained with the guys in vegas and I
go,
did everybody looked at me?
They said,
then you have a second career.
This is the craziest thing.
I said,
yeah,
there's this crazy right.
I'm feeling so good.
You know,
I could have ended a warm.
I couldn't to do 20 minutes of warm up
when I started because I didn't train
for three and a half years and six weeks
later I'm not taking breaks anymore.
I just go into the next opponents.
I was,
even myself,
I am a single man.
This is great.
And then all the injury started coming
back and now I go,
okay,
now I got it.
My knees,
my tendinitis.
I tore a hamstring,
pull the rip,
rip out at the place at the dan
henderson's place,
you know,
they took me down in the mid air.
I reversed the take down,
but with that I use so much upper bodY
strength strength that I popped the rip
out.
So now there was 12 days before the
fight I couldn't punch anymore.
Can point you back.
The only thing I did was the workout.
I have the audio workout in the air and
it was the only thing I could do.
Wow.
Yeah.
So what you got out of this,
the sport
with your faculties,
100 percent intact,
that is the ultimate goal of any fighter
to retire.
And especially you because you're now a
commentator,
you're also an analyst,
mean what you do,
a fantastic job of breaking down fights,
uh,
really enjoy you on inside mma because
you have such a knowledgeabLe
perspective.
but also you're very honest.
You don't play politics.
You're very honest about how you feel
about a fight coming up about where it
guy fucked up.
but we're where a person's chances lie.
And I think it's,
uh,
it's,
it's amazing what you've done.
It really is amazing.
Thank you.
You're sharp ever.
I,
you knoW,
I'm almost trying not to get hit,
you know,
it didn't really work in my tunnel
fighting as kevin
because he'd beat the crap out of me,
but the first four minutes,
but,
you know,
but after that it was okay for the rest.
I don't think I ever got hit,
you know,
I,
I always try to,
you know,
slip and move or fighting intelligent is
most important aspect of fighting to use
your mind to use your mind and proper
tactics and techniques.
That's why I love mighty mouse.
Mighty mouse is on.
Yeah,
I agree.
I mean,
I don't think there's any competition.
I'm think jon jones is a phenomenal
talent and he's an amazing fighter,
but I think it's,
it's almost disrespectful to put him as
pound for pound the best when you look
at some of the wars that he's had with
gustafson.
I mean the war that he had with daniel
cormier was daniel.
Obviously he's a great fighter,
is a really good fight in,
you know,
john won the fight of course clearly,
but you look at what mighty mouse is
going into.
The competition doesn't even get hit.
Dodson is a fucking freak.
Yep.
I mean dotson's a freak and dotson just
couldn't touch him.
Dotson.
Elvis said in the beginning,
it's like he's glued to the ground,
like he moves back.
You'd never slipped.
She never just grateful to work,
but the man dj who met tom did a really
good job.
That's a really,
uh,
that's.
Yeah,
that's a whole new level where he's got
so much going on in his mind.
He's very smart.
He's very dedicated.
He's got a great control of his ego.
He doesn't fight like a fully fights.
Very,
very technical.
His footwork is fantastic.
He's his choices that he makes it a
fight.
He's unpredictable in his movements.
It's Just,
I think he's the best ever.
I really do.
He needs to guide to fight like a
carnival gregor though,
because.
So he has a big payday one day because
rafael dos anjos is going to make a lot
of money.
This fight,
you know,
if a 2 million,
if that's really going to hit it.
Yeah.
And,
and you watch that,
we'll probably get up also if he,
if for some reason mcgregor wins this
because you're going to be very hard to
fight for him because I think a dos
anjos yeah.
It's going to be verY tough fight
because we saw with mendez.
Yeah.
Well we'll,
we'll noTice.
Same thing,
you know,
once it goes to the ground,
but you still don't know in that fight.
He is so aware of where he is.
When he fought mendez and I talking
about mcgregor,
he was Just laying on the ground,
you know,
he didn't even try to escape.
It was almost like he said,
oh,
he's going to run out of gas.
Mendez tooK that fight on two weeks.
That's what I mean.
Just different as you could have done
that.
But he knew that.
That's what I'm saying.
He knew,
oh,
I'm just going to carry it into the
second round and I'm going to get them,
you know,
didn't even try.
So I think once against the rafael dos
anjos yeah,
he's going to need this.
Go into the garden.
That's one thing for sure.
It's a different aniMal.
He'll be there every minute of every
round.
He'd be There for 25 minutes trying to
kill you.
Yeah.
Dos anjos is a fucking animal man.
He's an animal.
It's a different animal.
Totally different kind of a fight.
So I'm so curious as to how that's going
to play out.
When you look aT how obsessed connor is
with footwork and movement and being
smooth and fast and laying like one of
the things that he said when I was
interviewing them after the fight,
he's like,
no power lucy,
that no power,
just precision,
just precision.
Like all those come out.
He just drops out,
punch in.
I mean,
he's not,
he's not grunting.
He's not.
He just drops it in and boom.
It takes them out.
The thing is I see him everywhere,
so I hope he's not gonna make the rousey
mistake because I said it two weeks
before.
I think what she's doing is not good.
She said,
every talk show every mexican I go to
the supermarket,
three magazine covers.
I mean,
iT's insane.
Stopped doing that,
you know,
fight first,
fight first.
That makes you big,
you know,
once you lose that,
all the other stuff that you're doing
right now is going to go as well because
they want that champion,
you know,
so mcgregor,
I hope that he keeps,
stays focused and only picks the ones
that he needs to do contractually.
And that's It.
Yeah.
I think he's going to be a lot smarter
about.
I think rhonda just got overwhelmed with
the amount of superstardom that came her
way.
Unprecedented him.
I mean,
there's never been an athlete like that
before.
This female ass kicker who's on top of
the world.
I mean she was a new thing and because
of that there were so many temptations
and,
and that's why for her it's also what's
so,
so hard.
When she lost,
she was such a high,
you know,
and then boom,
there you have such a low that well does
the auto,
this is how your opponents could have
felt,
you know,
and I think that kind of stuff,
you don't want one side,
it's really good for her because now she
understands that now she's going to go,
oh,
okay.
No,
I tasted the other side.
You're going to make you a better
person.
Then you start reminiscing about all the
things.
Did I,
you know,
what I owe and that interview I wasn't
really.
That wasn't really cool.
You know,
those things are backfiring once you
said losing as mcgregor,
the same thing.
Although with him there's always.
It's a funny thing,
you know,
with rhonda,
it's real,
like real,
real,
but mcgregor said,
will he do the reason is so
unbelievable.
He good?
Is he in his mind?
He truly lives.
There's no way he could lose,
you know,
and a guy was a guy like that.
Mendez hit them hard.
I mean heart and he didn't even flinch.
There was no zero,
no movement.
Crazy.
It was the craziest thing we sell.
Mendez took out ricardo lopez,
ricardo lamas rather,
luggage mendez.
It's fucking hard.
That's a hard area.
Connor Just eats it.
Each on the tip of his job.
It was not like,
just crazy.
Yeah,
his chart,
his jaw is incredible.
His mind is incredible.
I'm so fascinated by that fight.
so fascinating.
He says,
we're one for one of us,
goes to order.
We all go to work all the way back.
When he said that,
remember in boston was that.
That was,
that's where he got me.
That's when roadway.
I said,
okay,
this guy,
that's why we got to worry about on the
inside of way we wanted and then the
next time it wasn't inside mma.
He says,
man,
I got my water grabs look in in my
suits.
How cool is that?
He was so happy.
He got his name.
And did you ever see the video?
Oh,
I did some homework on him because we
were going to interview him and I saw
this video.
It isn't a hotel and in in dublin I
believe,
and there's coconuts to just see that
boat now.
Okay.
So he's talking into the camera that's
shooting this,
whatever you is the following him around
to suddenly,
here's why wife going no way.
Right.
And he goes,
he's talking to kevin,
he looks at and says,
says what?
He said,
no way.
And he says the one second.
So he walks over,
she,
she comes with a coconut and there's a
hole in there that put a little cork
thing in there.
So he goes,
no way.
He never saw it.
Coconut.
So they pull the thing I think with the
straw and go or no way.
You think they did this for a bit
because I have to fight a brazilian guy
and that's why they put their start
reminiscing and that is a knock on the
door.
So He opened the door and he has the
cognitive dissonance.
This trainer at a trade that sees the
co,
he does her,
the trader goes,
no way.
Everybody does.
It is so funny.
And then you see him at the attic.
He lifts at the attic from his mom and
dad with his wife the attic and he's
putting a suit on and he's trying to
figure out a thing in the pocket,
you know,
and he goes,
I don't know how to do it,
but you know,
I,
I think in a few years from now,
I will say though,
it's,
this becomes second nature and then you
see him now.
How cool is that?
You're really there and now all the way
up there.
Good guy.
Well,
he's making so much money now.
It's unprecedented.
I was talking to dana on the phone today
and dana was saying he's going to be the
first guy to make $100,000,000,
although made $5,000,000 from that last
fight.
Aldo did $5 million,
$5 million and all those going back to
Brazil with that moneY where it's worth
probably like who knows,
15,
20,
something like that.
I mean in,
in,
for a guy like aldo who loves Brazil and
loves to be in Brazil,
that money goes a long way in Brazil,
you know when you can help a lot of
people in Brazil with that money to.
Whereas if you bring That money to
America,
I mean $5,000,000,000 in los angeles,
you can get it in house and then it's
gone.
But in Brazil he can,
he can hold onto that money for a long
time.
well,
who knows how much current is going to
make in this dos dos anjos fight and
even if he loses you still defenses,
featherweight title,
which is crazy.
What if he fucking wins?
If he fucking winter,
then he goes up and fights robbie lawler
at welterweight.
Oh yeah.
Wonder boy,
it's going to be insane.
That's what a boy has.
The same kind of timing that he asked is
different.
I always talk about distance as
yesterday in my class.
I said again,
the most important thing if fighting
fish,
keep your nose pointed to your opponent
because if you say ice that they think
looking away dishes is not keep you full
vision and distance.
You know if you,
if you manage to stay just outside this
reach and then you can counter,
it's golden.
That's what.
You know what a boy wonder boy has that
no one has his karate kicks.
He's got the front leg side kick to the
body,
the front leg roundhouse kick to the
face when he was fucking Johnny
Hendricks up with that.
He front leg side,
kick them to the body and then frontline
roundhouse kicked him in the face.
You can see hendrix was like,
whoa,
what is this?
Yeah,
he kicks in a way that no one does.
No one.
Like when he wheeled kicked allen burger
ellenberger was saying before that
fight,
those kicks are a waste of time.
He's like,
I think it's a waste of energy.
All that spinning stuff.
He'll kick some
hope solo is a big fan.
Did you see that?
Oh,
hope solo made.
I made a video message for wonder.
Boy loves him.
How cool Is that?
Amazing.
Yeah.
His fight with hendrix was his coming
out moment like where you really got to
see him with all of his work that he's
done with wide and his take down defense
and his wrestling and you're seeing that
kickboxing that we always knew we had
with the 57 and o kickbox is.
You think you're seeing it come together
inside the octagon.
Where is all these other mma skills have
caught up with his kickboxing?
fuck man,
that guy is good.
Yeah.
You something.
I was so impressed wiTh that fight with
hendrix.
I was so impressed with him when his
father said it before.
If I was talking about the distance,
you know,
I go,
oh,
well let's see.
And then when I saw it,
The footwork,
it's like a snake.
He's like in and out and he wrestled.
Did he has to be right?
I mean,
how does he stands?
He's,
first of all,
it's done a lot of work with weidMan.
Him and weidman trained together a lot
and also he's carlos machado.
Son-in-law.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right.
So he mean he's learning jujitsu,
I'm sure from.
I mean,
I don't know what belty has under that,
but jesus christ,
that's a high level.
It's a beautiful thing to be connected
to that.
How.
How did I hear something that he was
going to be like family of light
minnows.
What was the connection to.
Is she going to live there now while he
trains with them a lot.
There's a big wide men,
of course,
elite wrestler.
No,
ncaa all american.
I mean one of the best wrestlers right
now in mma,
so to have a guy like weidman training,
I knew that they do a lot of training
sessions at hofstra.
They'd go down there and do a lot of
work with the wrestling,
but that's what he needed.
He needed to be able to confidently stay
on his feet and not worry about
executing the kicks because you see them
earlier in his career.
He just didn't.
It wasn't loose,
it wasn't loose the way he is in a
kickboxing fight.
Did you ever see him in the world combat
leak?
Chuck norrIs's organization?
Oh my god.
You see them in pure kickboxing.
You see what a talent.
This kid is just incredible and we're
going to watch it,
but it's so unusual because iT's hands
down and loose and in and out like a
snake.
Trying to find a guy who emulates those.
I mean leona machida is obviously got
great karate skill,
but wonder boys on another level.
it's like several levels past that.
The combinations that guy throws.
Like when he hit hendricks,
he's tagging them and then as he slide
now,
roundhouse kicks them in the body and
then he slides back in and hit them with
another combination and then he slides
out,
slides back in again and hendrix is just
overwhelmed.
He never saw anybody do that to hendrix.
Yeah,
I think um,
what's interesting to try with guys like
that elvis said this with cheeto show
and even with conor mcgregor and when he
fought aldo and,
and,
and in this case now as well,
because the stance is so karate white,
right?
But it's a karate with low kicks there
used to here iN America,
you know,
so I'm,
I said to my buddies,
I imagine that I'm the camp former aldo
said four months ago.
Listen,
you're going to face mcgregor eventually
is going to happen.
Let's switch you to south pole so we can
use your left low kicks.
It goes,
the way they stand,
It's going to be very hard for them to
get away from low kicks on the outside
inside is easy because what mcgregor
does,
he lowers himself and once his knee goes
in the same line as this,
but so to say,
you don't,
you don't have any space to land that
inside located.
It's really weird.
If you angle it up,
the angle is gone,
but low kicks in that stand outside
located outside low kicks froM the
southpaw stance,
from a southpaw stance,
powerful loki.
So that lag,
because if you stop the legs,
you're going stop every.
Well nikki holtz getting Raymond Daniels
because raymond danIels is a very
similar style.
Daniels,
of course it was a karate champion as
unbelievable kicking Talent,
but nikki hall skin stays glued to him
and throws leg kicks.
It just chops them down,
chops them down,
champs him down,
and then beats them up.
And that's the same thing with joseph
valtellina st did the same thing with
Raymond Daniels.
Yep.
Chop them down with low kicks,
chop them down with low kicks.
And then he had ticked them and knocked
them out of linea is also something.
Yeah.
Wow.
But he's another guy that he.
He had to relinquish his title because
of concussions and he's going to do the
podcast soon.
We're Talking about him coming on the
podcast because he wants to talk about
some of the situations he's gone through
dealing with concussion syndrome.
Wow.
Yeah.
And he's young.
Yup.
Yeah,
just hard training.
Hard fights.
Nikki holds can fight was hard.
You know,
he's had,
he sent some fucking wars,
you know,
he has see in training we never.
Like I never get knocked out thankfully,
but I could hit a few times,
but never,
you know,
not every workout for sure,
like ones that are just so many time.
It will be good to have good sparring
partners.
It always happens when you go somewhere
and then one of these at a boxing club,
but ceRtainly a boxer jumps up,
hey,
you want to go for your run?
And then it goes harder,
harder,
and then.
Yeah,
well that's one of the smart things that
Conor does.
Connor keeps all of his training
partners very close.
You know,
he's got all these guys got gunnar
nelson,
he's got a bunch of different guys that
he trains with on a regular basis and he
keeps those guys very close to him and
everybody's got a common goal.
Everybody's trying to help everybody
else.
Everybody's trying to get themselves
healthy so that they're going to be
stepping into that cage at 100 percent.
That's it.
Winning combination.
See,
he doesn't break it.
Winning combination.
He takes everybody from Ireland,
but just come with me.
Very smart,
very smart.
I gotta get the fuck out of here.
Boss,
route it,
but I appreciate the fuck audio.
You're awesome.
Anytime.
Invitation.
Morrow,
we're going to talk about it again.
Crazy.
Yes.
I'm crazy.
A bright stories.
People are gonna like let them heal up
or get over his illness and we'll
reschedule it soon.
I would love,
love,
love to do that.
Please check out rutan and rinaldo.
It's available on soundcloud is on
itunes.
It's on everything.
Yep,
and of course inside and my mates on
access tv boss rutan,
el guapo.
Great one.
Godspeed.
Potty on.
Thank you sir.
Thank you.